la séance est ouverte le compte rendu
intégral de la séance du jeudi 6 octobre
a été publié sur le site internet du
Sénat il n'y a pas d'observation
le procès-verbal est adopté l'ordre du
jour appelle le scrutin pour l'élection
d'un juge suppléant à la Cour de Justice
de la République
mes chers collègues il va être procédé
dans les conditions prévues par
l'article 86 bises du règlement au
scrutin secret pour l'élection à la Cour
de Justice de la République ce scrutin
se déroulera dans la salle des
conférences et la séance ne sera pas
suspendue durant les opérations de vote
je rappelle que la majorité absolue des
suffrages exprimés et requises pour être
élu
une seule délégation de vote est admise
par sénateurs et je remercie nos
collègues victoires jasmin et Marie
Mercier secrétaire du Sénat qui vont
superviser ce scrutin
le juge à la Cour de Justice de la
République nouvellement élue sera
immédiatement appelé à prêter serment
devant le Sénat je déclare ouvert le
scrutin pour l'élection d'un juge
suppléant à la Cour de Justice de la
République il sera clos dans une
demi-heure
du jour appelle la discussion du projet
de loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur la procédure
accélérée a été engagée sur ce texte et
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer monsieur
le ministre
bien Madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs veut se
présente de la commission des lois
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
l'honneur de présenter devant vous au
nom du Gouvernement de la République la
loi d'orientation et programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur
c'est un moment très important pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur et l'ensemble
des services qui concourent à la
sécurité des Français sécurité avec un S
sécurité au sens où nous l'entendons
évidemment c'est sécurité lutte contre
la délinquance mais également sécurité
civile
on a vu à quel point cet été les
Français étaient de plus en plus
inquiets des difficultés qui pouvaient
naître évidemment d'un mauvais modèle de
sécurité civile c'est sécurité cyber on
voit bien à quel point l'actualité nous
pousse à réfléchir à ces sujets très
importants
sécurité et intérieures puisque nous
avons aussi des dispositions monsieur
les rapporteurs vous l'avez constaté sur
l'organisation territoriale de l'État le
rôle des préfets des sous-préfet des
agents préfectures dans l'action de ce
ministère
le hasard mais pas totalement le hasard
vu que le calendrier de ce texte ici
arrive en même temps que la loi de
finances à l'Assemblée nationale puisque
cette loi de programmation prévoit 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires sur
les 5 ans à venir ces 15 milliards
d'euros la programmation de du texte de
loi que nous vous présentons va de pair
avec la loi de programmation des
finances publiques et la loi de finances
pour l'année 2023 qui prévoit bien
l'augmentation de ces 15 milliards
d'euros si j'osais dire c'est une loi
d'orientation qui est déjà concrète
puisque le Parlement votera en même
temps les crédits nous l'espérons dans
la chambre basse et demain je l'espère
dans la chambre haute
pourquoi une loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur parce que nous
avons considéré que les enjeux qui sont
devant nous qui sont devant le peuple
français mérité comme pour nos amis
militaires une loi de programmation à
une échelle assez longue 50 qui n'a
jamais eu
d'expérience précédente dans la nal du
ministère de l'Intérieur pourquoi parce
que auparavant il y a eu des lobsi des
lois d'orientation et programmation de
la sécurité intérieure il n'y a jamais
eu de l'autre mi pardon pour ce jeu de
mot de programmation de l'ensemble du
ministère de l'Intérieur
et si les lobsi précédentes ont permis
de faire évoluer évoluer pardon la
sécurité intérieure la première
notamment en faisant venir l'image et la
vidéo surveillance lorsque Nicolas
Sarkozy était mise à l'intérieur la
deuxième en revoyant la façon dont on
organisait la sécurité publique dans le
cadre de la RGP parce que Nicolas
Sarkozy était président de la République
le ministère de l'Intérieur n'a jamais
connu sur 5 ans des programmations
budgétaires importantes qui permet non
pas de répondre aux problèmes ici et
maintenant qui évidemment concerne
chacune et chacun d'entre nous le
ministère et le ministre de l'Intérieur
en premier lieu la délinquance coin de
la rue le point de stup qu'on n'arrive
pas à résorber la personne qu'il faut
accueillir dans le commissariat et bien
réfléchir à demain c'est à dire aux
crises de demain
et Mesdames et Messieurs dessinateurs je
veux ici défendre le texte en évoquant
les cinq crises auxquelles ce texte
essaie de répondre en y mettant après ce
constat des stratégies et des moyens
budgétaires
la première des crises qui est devant
nous et qui est toujours persistante
c'est la crise terroriste je veux redire
ici devant la hotte assemblée que la
menace terroriste est extrêmement
prégnante sur le territoire national
dans tout le monde et le monde
occidental en particulier mais en France
bien évidemment je ne reviendrai pas sur
les causes de cette monastère en France
elle a beaucoup de raisons mais nous
devons constater que si nous avons des
jouets plus de 39 attentats depuis que
le Président de la République est
présent de la République les
informations qui nous parviennent les
analyses de ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays et sans doute la
prospective qui doit naître d'un grand
ministère aussi de ministère d'intérieur
évoque le fait que cette menace
terroriste est d'autant plus prégnante
qu'elle se modernise qu'elle se
technologie et il peut être peut-être
farfelu devant vous d'évoquer le fait
que les attentats de demain ne seront
pas simplement des attentats commis avec
une arme dans une salle de spectacle ou
avec un couteau en dehors d'une
boulangerie mais par un drone
chargé d'explosif qui pourrait foncer
sur une foule et créer ainsi comme sur
les théâtres d'opérations extérieures la
terreur comme nous la connaissons
malheureusement sur d'autres armes dites
plus traditionnelles
et c'est le travail du ministère de
l'Intérieur que de prévoir l'acte
terroriste de demain
cet acte terrible demain c'est notamment
la façon dont la loi de programmation
met des moyens extrêmement importants
pour pouvoir répondre à l'intervention
des forces de police et de manière
générale de l'État alors que le ces
réseaux radio par exemple sont
extrêmement éculés monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez accepté que le
gouvernement dépose en séance un
amendement qui prévoit en dur si j'ose
dire l'ordonnance qui était prévu pour
le réseau radio du futur c'est 2
milliards d'euros que nous vous
demandons dans la programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour que demain
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
l'ensemble des administrations qui
concourent à la sécurité des Français et
un seul et unique réseau radio capable
d'intervenir en images et en son partout
sur le territoire national et qui est
indépendamment des attaques quelles
qu'elles soient fonctionnent et
permettent à la sécurité civile comme
politique d'intervention type raid Berry
ou GIGN d'intervenir avec un seul réseau
de communication des sociétés françaises
ont gagné ce marché je peux désormais le
rendre public notamment la société
Airbus qui fait partie de celle qui a
gagné ce grand marché public que nous
avons lancé que nous espérons concrets
avec la loi évidemment voter et il est
évident que la crise terroriste de
demain fait naître évidemment un travail
d'anticipation la lutte antidrone dont
nous devons désormais nous prémunir mais
également de communication c'est le cas
du réseau radio du futur
la deuxième crise que je voudrais
évoquer ici c'est une crise d'ordre
public
chacun a pu constater à la faveur de la
crise des gilets jaunes que les
manifestations de papa étaient terminées
c'est fini du temps où les préfets ou
les ministres intérieurs se mettaient
d'accord éventuellement avec des grandes
organisations syndicales avec un service
d'ordre organisé et ce métier d'accord
sur les chemins même s'il y avait
plusieurs millions de personnes qui
manifestaient ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui soutenons-le et finalement
avec des policiers aguerris puisque
l'ordre public est un métier qui n'est
pas un métier fait par d'autres
policiers que ceux qui sont formés à
l'ordre public pouvait répondre à ces
manifestations nombreuses sans qu'il y
ait des débordements qui soient au-delà
de l'acceptable chacun désormais a vu
que les manifestations sont spontanées
numériques difficiles
sans organisateur aussi peu
peut déclarer avec bien évidemment une
multiplicité de manifestations sur le
territoire national alors qu'évidemment
les villes moyennes ou les villes plus
petites ne connaissaient pas ce qu'on
connu tous les samedis des gilets jaunes
des années précédentes
l'une des difficultés de ces
manifestations venaient du fait que nous
ayons un service de renseignement peu
organisé en tout cas peu organiser pour
comprendre ces manifestations nouvelles
qui touchent d'ailleurs l'ensemble du
monde occidental et pas simplement bien
sûr la France
et du nombre de policiers qu'il manquait
spécialiste dans l'ordre public pour
organiser ces manifestations je suis
bien malheureux objet de constater que
15 escadron de gendarmes gendarmerie et
de Cérès ont été supprimés ces 20
dernières années et lorsque la crise des
gilets jaunes est venue les nombres de
policiers spécialisés dans l'ordre
public qui demande un entraînement qui
demande un matériel qui demande un
nombre et une stratégie particulière
était peu nombreuses et ont parfois
forcé des policiers dont ce n'était pas
le métier on a parfois vu des policiers
municipaux utilisés par les mairies
parce que il fallait bien répondre aux
difficultés que nous connaissions des
difficultés extrêmement graves pour les
policiers eux-mêmes bien évidemment mais
aussi pour les manifestants et le
travail du ministre de l'intérieur c'est
de permettre aux manifestants même ceux
qui manifestent contre la police d'être
en sécurité le paradoxe démocratique
veut qu'il soit ainsi souligné prenons
en compte cette difficulté d'ordre
public nouvelle et ces manifestations de
nouvelles formules nous vous proposons
la recréation de 11 escadron de
gendarmerie mobile ou de CRS c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc depuis 25
ans réparti en 7 escadron de gendarmerie
mobile 4 unités de CRS 10 8 mobilemobile
dans l'occasion d'en parler monsieur le
rapporteur évidemment sur cette nouvelle
stratégie d'ordre public je voudrais
aussi souligner que le choix de recréer
cette unités d'escadron de gendarmerie
mobile répond aussi à nos difficultés
ultramarines vous savez que l'essentiel
est géré par des gendarmes mobiles et
non pas par des CRS et qu'il s'agisse
des événements potentiels en
Nouvelle-Calédonie des difficultés que
nous connaissons à Mayotte et en Guyane
il faut aussi savoir regarder les choses
telles qu'elles sont et il est fort à
parier que quel que soit le gouvernement
quel que soit la majorité des assemblées
le gouvernement de la République la
puissance publique aura besoin davantage
d'escadron de gendarmerie et de CRS pour
répondre à la fois aux manifestations
spontanées numériques et nouvelles et en
même temps aux crises
ultramarines que nous pouvons connaître
il s'agit donc de professionnaliser
l'ordre public encore plus que nous
avons fait jusqu'à présent et de s'en
donner les moyens et la recréation de
ces escadrons à partir de ce constat
méritent sans doute une loi de
programmation même si je veux ici
souligner que pendant les deux
prochaines années budgétaires nous
recréerons l'intégralité de ces 11
escadrons et CRS pour que nous soyons
prêts également pour les Jeux Olympiques
qui est notre grand rendez-vous si j'ose
dire et qui va rythmer cette loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur
crise terroriste crise d'ordre public
nous avons aussi à faire sans aucun
doute à une crise cyber
mesdames messieurs sénateurs la
prochaine pandémie que nous allons vivre
est sans doute une pandémie cyber nous
voyons bien les difficultés que tout le
monde connaît des grandes entreprises
mais aussi des plus petites dans chacune
et dans chacun des villages ou des
villes que vous connaissez qui sont vos
terres d'élection des collectivités
publiques qui sont attaquées quasiment
quotidiennement des hôpitaux publics à
qui on demande des rançons et évidemment
un certain nombre
de fonctionnement régulier des services
publics qui sont évidemment à la
porter d'attaque cyber qu'il s'agisse
d'un État étranger dans ce qu'on appelle
désormais une guerre qui ne dit pas son
nom
le groupe terroriste ou de groupe de
délinquants cyber qui peuvent ici
dévoiler le secret de la correspondance
là empêchait le fonctionnement d'un
service la demander des rançons qui se
joue qui se chiffre parfois en milliards
d'euros le ministère de l'intérieur
étant le ministère de la sécurité dans
son côté curatif le silence son côté
préventif doit être le ministère de la
Sécurité de demain
qui est déjà la sécurité d'aujourd'hui
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
savez-vous que plus de 50% des
escroqueries que vivent les Français
sont déjà des attaques cyber
quand une dame vient vous voir dans
votre permanence pour expliquer qu'elle
a reçu un mail que je connais pas
l'auteur et qui demande d'envoyer de
l'argent c'est déjà une attaque hiver
quand un monsieur vient vous expliquer
on lui fait du chantage à sa messagerie
personnelle c'est une attaque cyber et
ce qui vaut pour 50% des escroqueries
d'aujourd'hui il n'était que 15% il y a
encore deux ans va atteindre les quasi
100% dans les mois années qui viennent
songer mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
que pendant les Jeux de Tokyo qui
pourtant n'ont pas fait venir beaucoup
de public pandémie oblige 4 milliards
d'attaques cyber ont été relevés alors
que nous connaissions encore à passer un
peu lointain devant l'étendue désormais
des attaques quotidiennes des grandes
administrations des grandes entreprises
et une forte à parier que la Coupe du
monde de rugby mais surtout les Jeux
Olympiques vont faire naître des
dizaines sans doute de milliards
d'attaques cyber soit sur l'organisation
elle-même ou tout simplement combinée à
une attaque terroriste le scénario noir
que je veux dessiner ici auquel il faut
que nous nous préparions c'est à la fois
une attaque terroriste par exemple par
un drone imaginons le cas pendant la
cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux
Olympiques et en même temps une attaque
cyber sur les hôpitaux qui prévoiaient
un plan blanc dans la région parisienne
ce ne serait pas des dizaines ou des
centaines de morts que nous viendrons à
constater mais peut-être des milliers
il faut évidemment nous préparer à cela
et c'est pour cela que dans les 15
milliards d'euros que je viens
solliciter en plus dans cette loi de
programmation plus de la moitié 8
milliards sont consacrés
au service numérique et cyber du
ministère de l'Intérieur je vais ici
donc souligner que c'est pour moi de 15
% de dépenses de personnel que je
sollicite la Haute Assemblée dans ces
crédits et que c'est essentiellement du
matériel et pour plus de la moitié de
ses crédits pour du cyber ou du
numérique que je viens solliciter le
vote de la Haute Assemblée afin que la
voiture
numérique ou cyber du policier du
gendarme aille aussi vite que la voiture
numérique ou cyber du voleur je pense
que c'est ce que c'est de faire tous les
ministres de l'intérieur on cite
beaucoup que les morceaux en ce moment
au moins depuis que Clémenceau je crois
que il faut que nous rendre compte que
beaucoup de choses changent et que la
police n'est pas tout à fait la même
parce que la délinquance c'est pas tout
à fait la même que depuis que les
morceaux
quatrième crise après la crise
terroriste que nous attendons après la
crise cyber après la crise d'ordre
public il s'agit évidemment d'une crise
de violence et notamment des atteintes
aux personnes que nous voyons remonter
continuellement j'ai plus ce matin des
livrets les premiers chiffres de
violences constatées sur le territoire
national et pour une fois qu'il baisse
me réjouir notamment en agglomération
parisienne ou des baisses à deux
chiffres sont constatés mais il faut
bien voir Mesdames et Messieurs que la
crise de la violence qui touche
l'ensemble des pays occidentaux vient de
plusieurs raisons politiques
sociétales dont nous pouvons à l'envie
discourir mais aussi d'une crise de
l'investigation dans la police nationale
et un peu dans la gendarmerie nationale
nous mettons depuis plusieurs années
beaucoup plus de personnes sur la voie
publique les interprétations sont plus
nombreuses plus 40% de trafiquants de
stupéfiants arrêtés par exemple mais une
fois que nous avons mis plus de
policiers de gendarmes sur la République
une fois que nous avons mis plus de
moyens pour interpeller les personnes il
faut faire des enquêtes et des
procédures judiciaires et pour ça il
faut des personnes qualifiées comme tel
et que nous disent les services de
police et de gendarmerie d'abord qu'il
n'y a pas assez de PJ
les EPJ sont évidemment un maillon
extrêmement essentiel pour que la
procédure soit bonne afin que présenter
devant magistrats les personnes peuvent
être lui cette justement condamnés et je
veux dire ici que lorsque les personnes
ne sont pas pour la société parfois même
pour les policiers justement condamnés
il faut aussi balayer devant la porte du
ministère de l'Intérieur et améliorer
les procédures judiciaires que nous
fournissons à l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires de la justice il y a trop
d'avocats assez spécialisés pour pas
voir que la forme qu'on puisse souvent
que le fond et que une procédure cassée
alors que nous avons mis des mois et des
mois pour retrouver tel ou tel
délinquant au criminel ne peut pas
l'être sur la forme sans que nous soyons
particulièrement interrogatifs sur le
contenu de cette procédure il faut donc
augmenter le nombre de pays
il y a un manque à peu près de 5000
officiers de police judiciaires dans la
police nationale c'est un manque
structurant et je veux dire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que lorsque vous
m'écrivez pour avoir davantage de
policiers dans vos circonscriptions je
suis heureux de vous accorder lorsque je
le peux grâce au crédit voté ces
policiers qui sortent d'école mais le
ministre de l'Intérieur n'a pas dans son
pouvoir la possibilité d'affecter de
force des objets dans vos commissariats
ou dans vos services spécialisés nous
ouvrons des postes mais si les gens n'y
viennent pas nous ne pouvons pas les
forcer
alors nous avons réfléchi à améliorer
cette crise de l'investigation sans
laquelle il n'y ait pas de réponse
pénale forte et il n'y a pas non plus de
travail de police à long terme qui
vaille beaucoup de dispositions de la
loopnie monsieur le rapporteur de Brest
prévoit des améliorations
révolutionnaires pour les autres pays
notamment le fait que désormais le
policier ne va pas attendre trois ans à
sa sortie d'école pour passer le bloc
OPJ et désormais sortie d'école puisque
désormais les policiers font 12 mois de
formation chez les gardiens de la paix
au lieu de 8 il passeront le bloc OPJ
une partie d'entre eux le réussiront et
pourront donc être affectés directement
dans les commissariats en ayant la
qualité d'officier de police judiciaire
première amélioration deuxième
amélioration vous avez créé dans loi
sécurité globale la réserve
opérationnelle de la police nationale
sur le modèle de la gendarmerie
nationale et vous aurez pu constater que
désormais un peu partout en France des
civils donnent quelques jours de leur
temps par semaine par mois pour enrichir
les effectifs de police améliorant ainsi
le lien police population
nous avons décidé de leur donner la
possibilité de garder leurs qualités de
PJ quand on part à la retraite jusqu'à
présent un policier pouvait revenir dans
son commissariat la réserve
opérationnelle mais ne pouvait pas faire
les enquêtes judiciaires alors qu'il ne
pouvait la veille lorsqu'il n'était pas
parti en retraite deuxième amélioration
troisième amélioration nous créons des
assistants d'enquêtes je pense que c'est
un point qui a des occuper un certain
temps pendant ce débat c'est
révolutionnaires pour la police
nationale la gendarmerie nationale
que fait un magistrat notamment injuste
d'instruction
si ce n'est que d'avoir un greffier qui
l'aide pour le formalisme de la
procédure
le magistrat se concentre sur son
travail de magistrat pour lequel il a
été formé et longuement et bien formé
mais lorsqu'il s'agit de répondre à
l'avocat lorsqu'il s'agit de taper à
l'ordinateur lorsqu'il s'agit de pouvoir
passer des pièces de faire des
photocopies c'est bien un greffier qui
intervient et qui aide après évidemment
des qualifications et des formations le
magistrat se concentrer sur sa procédure
le policier lui fait tout
il accueille le gardien à vue il appelle
le médecin il répond sollicitations de
l'avocat dès la première heure de garde
à vue il fait les photocopies il tape à
l'ordinateur lorsque l'ordinateur
fonctionne de plus en plus il fonctionne
de la son crédit que vous nouveautés
donc c'est une très bonne chose il
répond aux interrogations du procureur
de la République ou de son substitut ce
qui est bien logique et on peut aussi
dire ici que tous les procureurs de la
République n'ont pas toujours la même
façon de travailler et que tous les OPJ
de France et donc on essaie de s'adapter
à chaque demande de tel ou tel procureur
et donc au lieu de dire telle les
démagogues que nous avons allégé les
droits de la défense pour alléger la
procédure pénale nous préférons dire que
nous allons aider les policiers à
remplir le formalisme nécessaire dans
chacun besoin s'il devait être accusé ce
qui est bien logique et laisser les
policiers se concentrer sur son travail
de policier ces assistants d'enquêtes
que nous créons c'est le personnel
administratif du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui fait un travail
formidable qu'on va monter en
compétences grâce à des formations on en
discutera j'imagine avec le rapporteur
de Bresse et qui vont faire tout le
travail
administratif et formel que font
aujourd'hui les policiers qui demain
pourront se concentrer intégralement à
leur procédures au service d'enquête aux
écoutes téléphoniques aux auditions aux
perquisitions mais pas à la photocopie à
la copie du dossier à l'appel du médecin
bref au formalisme qui est certes
extrêmement nécessaire mais qui est du
temps perdu pour l'officier de police
judiciaire
il y a quelques mois mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs vous ne m'avez longuement
interrogé sur la montre forfaitaire
délictuelle qui est inscrite aux tâches
et qui est une amende pénale je le
rappelle c'est pas une simple amende sur
la consommation de stupéfiants vous
m'avez demandé est-ce que ça marche
est-ce que ça a marché d'un côté il y a
ceux qui disaient ça marche pas et
l'autre il y a ceux qui disent on allait
déprécier la réponse pénale du
consommateur de cannabis sur la voie
publique
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs comme
beaucoup d'entre vous j'ai été maire
et lorsque je suis devenu mère une
première chose que j'ai fait c'est que
je suis allé avec des services de police
nationale de ma commune
pour faire comme je fais c'est pas très
original chacun des élus une tournée
avec
eux et à 23h30 dans le métro de
Tourcoing sur le rapporteur
je suis avec les effectifs de police et
là un monsieur sort de la RAM de métro
avec un joint de cannabis
et là le policier qui l'accompagnait
avec le commissaire de police qui ce
jour-là était venu quand même accompagné
de mère j'espère qu'ils le font tous les
soirs sans les mères et sans les
ministres
me dit Monsieur maire qu'est-ce qu'on
fait est-ce qu'on fait comme d'habitude
ou est-ce qu'on fait parce que vous êtes
là ça m'a rendu interrogatif
faites comme d'habitude et le
commissaire de police a pris le joint
l'ami par terre la
nettoyer d'un pied il a dit la personne
de s'en aller
agile et pourquoi vous voulez pas
interpeler Emilie Monsieur le Maire si
on interpelle quelqu'un qui fume un
joint dans le métro ça fait trois
personnes on sort du métro on l'amène au
commissariat c'est à 10 minutes on va
appeler procureur de la République on va
mettre en garde-vue on va notifié ses
droits il va appeler son avocat il va
appeler son médecin tout ça normal et au
bout de quelques heures peut-être
quelques dizaines de minutes le broker
la République va dire cher ami vous
pensez qu'on a pas autre chose que de
s'inquiéter à faire des procédures pour
des consommateurs de cannabis alors il y
a deux réponses à ça il y a ceux qui
disent faut légaliser ce n'est pas la
position du gouvernement
je crois que je l'ai assez répété c'est
pas la position de absolument tout le
monde non plus dans tous les partis cher
ami
parfois on cherche et parfois on trouve
c'est ce problème des chercheurs et la
deuxième option c'est de pouvoir
comprendre qu'on ne fait pas des garde à
vue et des peines de prison ferme pour
des consommateurs de cannabis mais qu'on
doit faire une réponse pénale qui ne
peut pas être que le rappel à la loi et
donc la mort l'amande forfaitaire
délictuelle qui ne concerne que les
majeurs et les non récidivistes
aujourd'hui fonctionne 260
000 amendes ont été mises depuis le mois
de septembre 2020
extrêmement recouverte puisque c'est
votre question plus que les amandes de
sécurité routière puisque nous avons
depuis quelques mois permis la saisie
automatique des
demandes de la Direction générale des
finances publiques sur les comptes
bancaires des personnes et donc nous
avons la fois une inscription au casier
et nous avons à la fois un recouvrement
de ces amandes et par ailleurs mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs ça permet
surtout aux policiers et aux gendarmes
de faire ses contrôles d'identité ou de
faire ses contrôles sur la voie publique
puisque chacun sait ici qu'ils ne le
font pas d'initiative sans une
instruction du procureur de la
République sans être PJ ou sans
effectivement avoir un but de le faire
comme l'amende forfaitaire délictuelle
le pire étant que le policier ou le
gendarme ne puisse pas faire le contrôle
identité ou la sanction d'une personne
qui manifestement trouble l'ordre public
d'une manière ou d'une autre et c'est
pour cela qu'une deuxième moment de
forfaitaire délictuelle est en ce moment
en train d'être mis en place et
expérimenté la fameuse occupation
illicite des oldim meubles un délit qui
avait
à rendre moins dur la sanction pénale
mais à la rendre plus certaine ce qui
compte mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ce n'est pas la dureté de la
sanction mais sa certitude il ne cherche
rien de condamner les gens à des peines
de prison qui ne font jamais des années
après leur sanction il sert tout en
revanche et notamment la force de la loi
que d'avoir la certitude de cette
sanction qu'elle soit effectivement
appliquée immédiatement et pour ça nous
devons nous reposer sur les policiers
sur les gendarmes qui sont des
auxiliaires de justice et qui agissent
au nom de la justice française et donc
j'ai proposé dans ce texte une
simplification de grande envergure de la
procédure pénale en faisant et c'était
la volonté du gouvernement dans un
premier temps que toutes les peines de
prison inférieures à un an et dont nous
savions qu'elle n'était pas appliquées
parce que nous pour considérions tous
qu'effectivement à force de regarder les
jurisprudences elle ne l'était pas et
sans récidive nous puissions les passer
en amande sans faire des rituel le
Conseil d'État a dit joint cette
disposition
et il a considéré que nous étions trop
large
le Sénat avait finalement même sur un
porteur ne dira deux possibilités soit
mettre des critères
soit faire une liste de
nous nous rangeons à la position du
rapporteur Hervé nous discuterons sans
doute de la nombre de ces délits mais
nous pensons effectivement que ces
hormones s'en fêtaient intellectuelles
par exemple faire un tag est-ce qu'on
est vraiment certain que ce tag mérite
pas une amende d'une inscription quasi
judiciaire plutôt qu'une procédure
pénale qui ne verra pas son
aboutissement et qui permettra à je
l'espère d'avoir une meilleure réponse à
ces désagréable action du quotidien et
donc nous aurons un débat très important
il s'en va évidemment avec la
simplification de la procédure nous
avons constaté également que le Sénat va
se tait enrichir sur un certain nombre
de délits je pense au rodéo ou à la
teinte aux élus et le gouvernement sera
avec sagesse à l'écoute de la Haute
Assemblée sur cette question je veux
dire à ceux qui attendent le grand soir
de l'échelle des peines que désolé de
décevoir je ne suis qu'un premier rideau
c'est monsieur le garde des sceaux qui
viendra vous présenter les étages
généraux de la justice le plus
rapidement sera le mieux je sais qu'il
travaille ardemment mais je ne me
permettrai pas de me substituer à Éric
Dupont-Moretti d'une part ce ne serait
pas logique dans les institutions
d'autre part vous seriez déçu
prise terroriste crise d'ordre public
crise cyber crise de la délinquance qui
fait naître la crise de l'investigation
Chris climatique
le texte ne parle pas que de sécurité ou
alors il parle de sécurité comme je dis
dans l'introduction au sens large notre
modèle de sécurité civile qui est
résilient qui est fondé sur des pompiers
valeureux qui est fondé sur un système
de volontariat original qui est fondée
sur des départements et un état et une
Europe qui aide fortement le
fonctionnement de notre pays se trouve
face à deux grands problèmes le premier
c'est que vous le savez les
sapeurs-pompiers interviennent de plus
en plus dans des domaines qui ne
relèvent pas de leur compétences
absolument propre et remplace de plus en
plus le médecin absent du désert médical
ou le système de santé difficilement
organisé pour répondre aujourd'hui à la
difficulté des Français je sais que
ministre de la santé il travaille
nous avons essayé de répondre à cette
question dans la loi matras que vous
allez avoir votée on a l'impression d'y
revenir mais surtout les crises
climatiques ne font que commencer on
pense tous au Méga feu ce qu'on touchait
la Gironde et d'autres départements bien
évidemment je veux ici dire qu'il y a eu
plus de feux au nord de la Loire au sud
de la Loire cet été avec des
départements comme le Jura les Vosges le
Maine-et-Loire le Finistère dont les
pompiers n'étaient évidemment ni S10 pas
habitué à intervenir pour des feux de
forêts de plus de 1000 hectares
et de l'autre côté il décrisent
climatiques extrêmement forte en
outre-mer mais aussi en métropole je
peux penser évidemment au début du
quinquennat ce qui s'est passé à
Saint-Martin avec Irma mais je peux
penser aussi à la vallée de la Vésubie
il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça où nous
avons été certes au rendez-vous avec
l'action de la sécurité civile et des
collectivités locales mais très en de ça
de ce qu'il faudrait préparer dans un
réchauffement climatique généralisé et
donc nous avons décidé de mettre un
certain nombre de disposition dans ce
texte à la fois de renouvellement de la
flotte je pense aux hélicoptères à la
fois de pouvoir du préfet en cas de
crise il n'a pas tous les mains
aujourd'hui pour travailler avec toutes
les agences et toutes les
administrations et vous savez que c'est
un drame dans la gestion des crises mais
aussi dans le travail que nous
souhaitons sans doute enrichir avec vous
des modèles de sécurité civile parce
qu'il faut désormais se rendre compte
que le réchauffement climatique étant au
rendez-vous et même s'il ne feux sur 10
sont d'origine humaine aujourd'hui les
taux d'hydrométrie font que les forêts
qui brûlent le brûlent très largement
moins de 10% de dans la forêt de Gironde
en imaginant même que l'incendie soit
d'origine criminelle ou involontaire et
donc il y a aussi une grande disposition
de grandes dispositions sur la sécurité
civile notre modèle de sécurité civile
dans ce texte alors je terminerai par
dire que j'aurai aussi l'honneur de
présenter en janvier prochain après un
débat au mois d'octobre et novembre ici
un texte sur l'immigration donc une
absente de ce texte mais pas absent de
la politique au gouvernementale je crois
que le scénar lui-même souhaitait des
textes resserrés on essaie de faire le
plus resserré possible avec un rapport
indexé certes assez long mais qui n'est
pas législatif et je terminerai par vous
dire Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires que nous sommes dans la
continuité
du réarmement du ministère de
l'intérieur des 200 brigades de
gendarmerie que nous allons recréer dans
l'ensemble de vos territoires lorsque le
gouvernement successif en a supprimé
plus de 500 depuis 30 ans
dans l'augmentation des effectifs de
police que nous continuons à faire dans
l'ensemble des commissariats de France
bien évidemment dans les 200 fourmisques
que nous créerons pour la sécurité
civile dans l'agence du numérique
puisqu'il faut créer l'impôt à la source
au ministère de l'Intérieur qui est un
ministère
un peu arriéré sur le numérique et qu'il
faut donc sans doute que nous
modernisions comme nous l'avons fait à
Bercy précédemment ça demande aussi
évidemment des moyens avec une agence
unique du numérique et puis avec pour la
première fois et le président de la
République a évoqué hier pour la
première fois depuis 17 ans mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la recréation de
sous-préfecture et la recréation
d'agents de préfecture dans les
préfectures puisque nous vous proposons
la création d'après 400 postes peut-être
pas encore assez mais pour la première
fois la reprise démographique du nombre
d'agents préfecture si important pour
nos territoires et au rendez-vous je
crois qu'à la fois le grand débat
président de la République avec les
maires de France mais aussi ce que nous
avons vécu par rapport des MI et le plan
de relance ont montré à quel point les
agents des préfectures étaient
importants en lien avec les
collectivités locales pour les aider en
ingénierie et de manière générale en
action publique de l'État voilà Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs l'honneur que
j'ai de présenter un texte qui je crois
est très important pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur
en le disant je veux ici l'ensemble
renverser ensemble du Parlement qui dans
sa quasi unanimité a toujours soutenu
les forces de l'ordre ou les forces de
sécurité civile qui vous le savez chaque
jour chaque nuit risque leur vie pour
nous protéger
j'ai
la grande
responsabilité de diriger en votre nom
les femmes et les hommes qui toujours
prennent ces risques et je ne peux pas
terminer mon discours sans penser au 17
enterrements que j'ai eu à présider et
je pense aussi aux 3400 blessés du plus
depuis le 1er janvier par exemple dans
les forces de l'ordre puisque notre
action collective derrière des chiffres
derrière des milliards derrière des
pourcentages derrière des textes
réglementaires ou législatifs derrière
des réformes c'est surtout l'action des
femmes et des hommes de terrain qui
n'ont aucun autre ministère
aucun autre ministère ne connaissent
autant le risque de la vie et en
terminant ce discours je veux leur dire
que si nous aurons des discussions
politiques je n'ignore pas que nous
faisons tous selon nos opinions elles
sont nos conviction le mieux pour les
protéger je vous remercie merci monsieur
le ministre
avant de laisser la parole à notre
collègue rapporteur Marc Philippe de
Bresse permettez-moi monsieur le
ministre de vous souhaiter en y
associant bien sûr mes collègues
sénateurs un très heureux anniversaire
au moment où changer de décennie
[Applaudissements]
alors mes chers collègues il est 15h06
je déclare clos le scrutin pour
l'élection d'un juge suppléant à la Cour
de Justice de la République
monsieur Marc-Philippe de Brest
rapporteur de la commission des lois
vous êtes invité à prendre la parole
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais à
mon tour remercier le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer de d'être
ici avec nous cet après-midi ne il fête
ses 40 ans aujourd'hui nous sommes
sensibles à cette marque de
considération puisqu'il nous a déposé un
texte il vient de le dire qui est très
important pour lui
pour son ministère pour les forces de
sécurité
et l'hommage que vous venez de le rendre
évidemment que nous nous y associons
pleinement et nous sommes très sensibles
à ce au sacrifice qu'ils font jour le
jour mais vous avez décidé de passer
l'après-midi la soirée avec nous
monsieur le ministre soyez rassurés
votre rapport fait 80 à 90 pages mais
nos collègues ont déposé sans cases
amendements sur l'article 1 donc nous
allons passer une bonne soirée
d'anniversaire en votre compagnie
mais chers collègues madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président de la
Commission de moi mes chers collègues la
genèse du projet de loi le ministre
vient de le dire qui nous rassemblent
aujourd'hui est longue il fait suite à
la publication du Livre blanc de la
sécurité et du beau veau de la sécurité
qui a été suivi avec beaucoup de
d'efficacité de compétences par notre
collègue Henri Leroy que je voudrais
remercier à nouveau et au dépôt vous
l'avez dit par le gouvernement d'une loi
d'un premier projet le 16 mars dernier
qui a été raccourci et resserrait
puisqu'il ne fait plus que 16 articles
de programmatique mais non des moines
puisque c'est une loi de programmation
et d'orientation j'ai eu l'honneur dans
ma vie politique d'être ministre délégué
auprès de Monsieur borload présenté moi
aussi une partie d'une noix de
programmation et d'orientation c'est une
loi très importante puisqu'elle engage
elle donne une vision à nos horizon et
qu'elle engage sur cinq années des
crédits budgétaires dont on espère
puisque vous y avez été je vous en parle
qu'ils ne seront pas des tricotés
toujours le jour par Bercy s'agissant
justement premier lieu de cette
programmation budgétaire le projet doit
prévoir dans son article d'une
progression chaque année du montant des
crédits de paiement et plafond des taxes
affectés à votre ministère au total 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires
seraient budgété sur 5 ans par rapport
au crédit affectés ministère de
l'Intérieur en 2022 c'est crédits
supplémentaires vous l'avez dit vont
permettre de financer des mesures de
modernisation et dans de nombreuses
investissements et vous y avez consacré
vous de l'avez souligné vous avez vous
avez raison beaucoup de moyens sur tout
ce qui est digitalisation numérisation
nouvelle technique utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle concernant
le rapport annexé nous avons adoptant
Commission des amendements sur plusieurs
thématiques importantes d'abord de
préciser dans le rapport annexé que la
réforme de la police nationale devra
prendre en compte les spécificités de la
police judiciaire dans le cadre de ces
enquêtes celle-ci doit rester sous
l'autorité fonctionnelle du procureur
continue à traiter seul des affaires
sensibles enfin au vu du développement
potentiel d'une délinquance organisée
qui dépasse les frontières
départementales il pourrait être utile
de prévoir des structures zonales la
commission des lois l'initiative de
notre président François Nouel buffet à
créant son sad mission d'information qui
va faire des préconisations et qui
soulignera les garanties apportées nul
doute monsieur le ministre que je pense
de n'en tiendrai compte à l'initiative
du groupe socialiste nous avons
également réaffirmé l'importance de
l'accessibilité des démarches
dématérialisées notamment pour les
personnes en situation de handicap sur
les articles 3 et 4 du projet de loi qui
vise adapter les prérogatives dont
dispose des forces de sécurité dans la
lutte contre les nouvelles menaces en
particulier les cyber menaces nous avons
pour l'essentiel soutenu la position du
gouvernement et
soutenu aussi toutes les crédits qui
permettront d'investir dans ces
technologies nouvelles s'agissant de
l'article 6 vous y avez fait allusion
monsieur le ministre qui vise à
permettre la prise de plainte et la
déposition par le recours à la
visioconférence il s'inscrit dans le
développement du recours à ces
dispositifs en matière de la procédure
pénale depuis les années 2000 je
rappelle que ces dispositions sont une
simple faculté non une obligation nous
avions prévu qu'ils ne concernerait que
les biens vous m'avez longuement
expliqué parce que nous avions sur
certaines atteintes aux personnes que
vous pensiez qu'on pouvait aller dans
élargir ce champ je ce matin la
Commission a fait appel à sagesse de
l'Assemblée je solliciterais donc votre
point de vue mais à titre personnel je
dois dire vous m'avez convaincu enfin
nos auditions montré l'urgence
d'améliorer la réponse pénale sur trois
enjeux essentiels les violences faites
aux élus vous l'avez dit vous-même plus
57% en un an les refus d'obtempérer vous
y avez fait allusion malheureusement
quand vous êtes obligé de d'être aux
côtés des familles dans les funérailles
plus 17% depuis un an et les rodés
urbains dont chacun a vu le feuilleton
cet été la Commission a donc prévu un
amendement pour protéger mieux nos
concitoyens et renforcer les sanctions
pour la discussion générale je dis à nos
collègues des groupes écologistes
communistes et socialistes ont présenté
de nombreux amendements qui tendent à
écrire la loi d'orientation que nous
avons essayé de trouver une cohérence
dans nos réponses d'une part parce qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de débats et en
commission et dans cette émission sur la
sécurité le dernier sur la sécurité
globale et le terrorisme et donc nous
sommes en cohérence par rapport à nos
jurisprudences précédentes et les
positions que nous avions prises sans
surprise et puis le président buffet a
créé deux missions d'information une
tuéphalusion sur la police judiciaire
l'autre sur la formation des forces de
police et de gendarmerie et nous pensons
qu'il faut attendre les préconisations
de ces missions d'information avant de
nous prononcer sur des amendements de
nos collègues qui veulent toujours
enrichir les formations donc ma position
sera constante ce qui fait que monsieur
le ministre que dans les 115 amendements
que nous allons examiner ce soir il y
aura fort peu d'avis favorables mais
parce que la Commission avait élaboré à
très bon texte d'ailleurs mon ami Loïc
Hervé va vous le démontrer à l'instant
partie de votre écoute mes collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Loïc Hervé
rapporteur de la commission des lois
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mon cher collègue
co-rapporteur mes chers collègues il me
revient maintenant après marquise de
Brest d'évoquer devant vous l'article 5
relatif au réseau radio du futur puis
les articles 7 à 16 du projet de loi la
plupart de ces articles ont été
approuvés par la commission des lois
nous avons considéré qu'il contribuerait
à simplifier la prostituée pénale et
qu'il donnerait aux forces de sécurité
intérieure de nouveaux outils juridiques
leur permettant de mieux remplir leur
mission la Commission a toutefois
réécrit les dispositions relatives à
l'amende forfaitaire délictuelle mais je
ministre vous l'avez évoqué elle a
enrichi le texte on y insérant certaines
mesures qui ne figurait dans la première
version de la loop me mais pas dans le
texte déposé par le Gouvernement sur le
bureau du Sénat concernant tout d'abord
le réseau radio du futur la commission
n'est bien sûr pas opposée à ce projet
qui vise à doter nos forces de sécurité
nos services de secours d'un réseau de
communication plus moderne et plus
résiliente la Commission va se prendre
en supprimer l'article 5 qui tendait à
habiliter le gouvernement à prendre par
ordonnance les mesures nécessaires à la
mise en oeuvre de ce projet nous
préférions que ces dispositions soient
inscrites en dur directement dans la loi
à l'occasion de l'examen du texte en
séance publique le gouvernement a donc
déposé un amendement en ce sens qui nous
donne satisfaction qui a pris en compte
nos observations et sur lequel nous
reviendrons lors de la discussion des
articles un ensemble de mesures pour
ambition de renforcer la filière en
charge de l'investigation au sein de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale
afin d'améliorer l'efficacité des
enquêtes compte tenu de la désaffection
dont souffre depuis trop longtemps la
police judiciaire ces mesures nous
paraissent aller dans le bon sens je
citerai en particulier la proposition de
recruter
5500 assistants d'enquête chargé de
veiller au respect de la procédure c'est
qu'il libérera du temps pour les
enquêteurs qui pourront ainsi se
concentrer sur leur cœur de métier la
Commission a souhaité qu'une évaluation
soit réalisée dans trois ans de la
plus-value apportée par ce nouveau cadre
d'emploi elle a également adopté un
amendement de notre collègue Alain
Richard tendance à mieux encadrer la
compétence accordée aux futurs
assistants d'enquête en matière de
transcription des enregistrements ce qui
répond à une inquiétude exprimée par le
Conseil d'État pour renforcer les
effectifs de la police judiciaire il est
prévu que les policiers et gendarmes
puissent passer l'examen pour devenir au
PJ officier de police judiciaire dès la
fin de leur formation la Commission a
adopter deux mesures complémentaires
premièrement les élèves officiers de la
Gendarmerie recevraient la qualité
d'agents de police judiciaire ce qui est
déjà le cas pour les élèves au sujet de
la police et les prérogatives d'agents
de police judiciaire sera étendu sous le
contrôle permanent d'un OPJ
la commission mais en revanche pas été
convaincue par la proposition de
généraliser la procédure de l'amende
forfaitaire délictuelle à tous les
délits de moins d'un an d'emprisonnement
puni par mois d'un entrepreneurs ce qui
correspondrait dans notre pays à 3400
infractions pénales la procédure de
l'amende forfaitaire a fait ses preuves
pour supprimer certains délits qui
peuvent être aisément constatés par les
forces de l'ordre je pense à la
consommation des stupéfiants et je me
range à la démonstration faite tout à
l'heure par Monsieur le Ministre mais
mais ce sont des des infractions qui ne
constituent c'est une réponse qui ne
constitue pas la panacée pour toutes les
infractions pour désengorger les
tribunaux ni pour lutter contre la
séchori l'insécurité au quotidien c'est
pourquoi la Commission a refusé cette
généralisation au profit d'une extension
limitée à quelques délits pour lesquels
l'amende forfaitaire nous paraît plus
adapté je pense aux tags aux délits
d'entrave à la circulation encore la
détention sans permis d'un chien
d'attaque je terminerai madame de mon
exposé en évoquant deux autres mesures
notables qui furent dans ce texte
d'abord la proposition de réprimer plus
serrément l'outrage sexiste qui
deviendrait un délit en cas de
circonstance aggravante la Commission
ifavables et elle enverrait un signal de
fermeté aux auteurs de cette infraction
encore trop peu réprimé sur le terrain
ensuite à l'article 15 la proposition
d'accroître les prérogatives des préfets
de département en cas de crise d'une
partie culière gravité l'objectif est
qu'il puisse exercer pleinement leur
autorité sur tous les services des
concentrés pour faire face à des
événements exceptionnels tel que nous en
avons d'ailleurs connu ces derniers mois
sur notre proposition la Commission a
souhaité étant de ce dispositif aux
agences régionales de santé les ARS
qu'ils ne nous paraît pas justifiés à la
lumière notamment de ce que nous avons
observé pendant la crise du covid de
maintenir à l'écart de cette unité de
commandement à l'échelle départementale
la Commission espère que ces mesures
législatives qui pourront être enrichies
au cours de notre discussion combiné à
l'accroissement des moyens des effectifs
contribueront à améliorer la sécurité
des Français beaucoup reste à faire mais
il s'agit d'un pas dans la bonne
direction qui nous conduit à soutenir
l'adoption de ce texte merci beaucoup
monsieur le rapporteur la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe Paul rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
s'inscrit dans un long processus entamé
il y a déjà plusieurs années on se
souviendra particulièrement de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur l'état
des forces de sécurité intérieure sous
l'égide de François grosdiguier et
Michel bouton qui avait déjà attiré
l'attention sur les causes du malaise
policier en 2018 la proposition numéro
10 du rapport de la commission d'enquête
était la suivante et élaborer un livre
blanc de la sécurité intérieure puis
adopter une loi de programmation
permettant de fixer un cadre budgétaire
opérationnel et stratégique stable et
crédible
nous vous savons nous vous savons donc
ré aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
d'avoir mené à bien ces travaux du Livre
blanc puis le beau mot de la sécurité
qui a permis de prendre d'importantes
mesures en faveur des policiers des
gendarmes ainsi les grandes orientations
du rapport annexique nous vous
apparaissent pertinentes et nécessaire
transformation numérique accélérée
augmentation de la présence sur la voie
publique lutte contre les violences
intrafamilales prévention des crises
telles sont effectivement les grands
défis que nous avons affrontés pour que
nos forces de sécurité soient plus
efficaces et plus crédible contre la
délinquance en constante évolution en
outre les 15 milliards prévus pour mener
à bien l'ensemble de ces transformations
et celles qui concerne les autres
missions du ministère de l'Intérieur
représentent un effort important sans
doute à la hauteur de l'enjeu en
revanche nous restons un peu sur notre
fin sur le lien qui existe entre ces
grandes orientations et cette
programmation des moyens en effet ce
texte est trop centré sur la sécurité
pour être une véritable loi
d'orientation de l'ensemble du ministère
de l'intérieur mais en même temps il est
trop imprécis sur les moyens accordés
aux missions des policiers et des gend
pour être une véritable loi de
programmation de la sécurité ainsi
monsieur le ministre vous savez que nous
sommes nous sommes inquiétés à mettre
plusieurs reprises de l'État indigne
d'une grande partie du parking
immobilier domanial de la gendarmerie
nationale sur ce sujet rien de précis
dans le texte il nous faudra si l'on en
croit le rapport annexer attendre encore
la mise en place d'un nouveau service
chargé des établir à temps mensuel de
dépense pourtant ne considérez-vous pas
les que les moyens sont déjà bien
identifiés et qu'il est urgent d'agir
c'est en tout cas notre conviction d'où
les amendements apportés par notre
commission enfin nous regrettons une
certaine précipitation dans la mise en
place des 200 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie nous craignons que les
collectivités soient sollicitées alors
que certains ne peuvent pas se permettre
un tel investissement ce qui a motivé
notre amendement commun avec la
commission des lois
pour finir je voudrais encore une fois
saluer l'engagement contre la
délinquance de l'ensemble de nos forces
de sécurité et en particulier pour ceux
qui concerne notre commission de la
gendarmerie nationale dont le statut
militaire reste pour nous la meilleure
garantie d'efficacité partout où elle
exerce sa compétence je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à madame Gisèle Jourdain
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées
monsieur madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues une des
grandes orientations de cette loi revêt
une importance particulière il s'agit de
celles qui prévoit de faire du
renforcement de la présence dans la
ruralité une nouvelle politique à part
entière la relocalisation de certains
services du ministère dans les
territoires ruraux et les villes
moyennes ou encore l'objectif de doubler
la présence des forces de sécurité sur
le terrain vont assurément dans le bon
sens tout comme le recours accru aux
réserves opérationnelles de la police et
gendarmerie nationale qui se sont rendus
indispensables dans de nombreux
territoires encore faut-il que
l'augmentation de leurs effectifs
aillent de père avec des missions
suffisamment nombreuses sur l’année
c'est ce dont nous avons vu lui nous
assurer par leur par l'un de nos
amendements il s'agit ainsi de permettre
un réel processus d'acquisition de
compétences et une fidélisation de des
qui se rendent de disponible pour des
missions au profit de la collectivité un
autre sens le chapitre consacré au
renforcement du maillage des forces de
sécurité dans les territoires ruraux et
périurbaines à un peu trop maigri
monsieur le ministre par rapport au
livre blanc les développements sur la
répartition territoriale des deux forces
s'étant évanoui en chemin seul annonce
concrète la création de 200 nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie sans autre
précision mon expérience locale
n'incline à penser que cette question de
la répartition des forces n'est pas
secondaire les deux forces ne sont pas
interchangeables la polyvalence de la
gendarmerie avec l'unité entre les
enquêteurs judiciaires et gendarmerie
départementale a renseigner dans le
territoire s'opposant à la
spécialisation policière il serait donc
préférable d'élaborer des critères
objectifs prenant en compte la réalité
de la délinquance afin d'effectuer des
ajustements fins plutôt que rester aux
critères simpliste actuels en ce qui
concerne la coopération entre les deux
forces sur un même territoire en cas
d'urgence ou des phénomènes particuliers
de délinquance il est également
nécessaire de généraliser les bonnes
pratiques autour des protocoles
départementaux police gendarmerie d'où
des amendements sur ces sujets connexes
enfin les modalités de la création des
200 brigades nous préoccupent notamment
en ce qui concerne la participation des
collectivités territoriales l'audition
du président de la commission sécurité
de l'AMF nous a confirmé dans ces
indoros dans ses interrogations autre
surprise les annonces sur le terrain qui
se sont succédées ces derniers jours
avant que nous le commencions l'examen
du texte je souhaite vraiment et nous
souhaitons que les débats d'aujourd'hui
permettront de dissiper tous ces outils
je vous remercie merci Madame la
rapporteur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Alain Richard
pour le groupe RDPI
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
voici un texte de grande importance qui
fait bien commencer de façon tonique
notre session et cette partie du mandat
gouvernemental et présidentiel ce texte
va définir le cadre des moyens humains
et matériels de nos forces de sécurité
pour les cinq années qui viennent de
façon ample puisqu'il y a une forte
augmentation des crédits et le rapport
prévoit aussi de façon cohérente les
grandes orientations d'emploi les
grandes finalités de ses moyens donc
nous avons là un document cohérent qui
réutilise en effet les débats qui ont eu
lieu et qui ont été très pluralistes
très partagé dans le Livre blanc et dans
le bobo de la sécurité il me semble donc
que c'est une un bon débouché de débats
qui ont été approfondis
je veux souligner aussi que la
programmation apparaît même des vertus
elle ne peut s'appliquer évidemment à
tous les ministères parce que sinon ça
viendrait très compliqué de faire un une
loi finance annuelle mais sur un sujet
comme la sécurité intérieure il me
semble que c'était une bonne option que
le ministre a bien fait de dépenser de
l'énergie et de la persuasion pour
arriver à une programmation qui nous
servira de de comment dire de balises en
quelque sorte à chaque loi de finance
pour vérifier que la continuité et la
l'organisation cohérente de ses moyens
se développe
et comme le ministre l'a dit j'avais pas
prolongé cette partie là ces moyens
bénéficient naturellement aux deux
grandes forces de sécurité intérieure
police nationale et gendarmerie
nationale avec une meilleure diffusion
territoriale mais bénéficie aussi de
façon très substantielle à la sécurité
civile et donc à tous les moyens de
lutte contre les catastrophes qui nous
qui nous assaillent
cette programmation bénéficie aussi à
tout l'environnement numérique ou plutôt
le support numérique du ministère qui
est qui va mettre en cohérence
toutes les fonctions opérationnelles de
sécurité intérieure et comme le ministre
la reconnu lui-même qui va faire sortir
le ministère d'une phase où il n'était
pas particulièrement en avance sur ce
sujet là donc on nous voyons des gains
de
d'efficacité opérationnelle qui vont se
poursuivre et enfin le ministre là aussi
noté et je voulais absolument faire
mention il y aura pour une pour la
première fois des recréations d'emplois
dans les préfectures alors que c'est
vrai que les personnels les préfectures
les cadres de ces de ces administrations
ont dû faire face à beaucoup de
réduction de moyens humains au cours des
15 20 dernières années et étaient dans
des conditions de travail qui était
souvent très tendues et je crois que
c'est ça sera excellent pour motiver les
les cadres des préfectures ajoutons que
tout ça va comporter des enjeux de
recrutement et de formation sur lesquels
le ministère devra bien sûr se mobiliser
je voudrais aussi mentionner puisque les
deux rapporteurs se sont bien répartis
le travail les principales dispositions
concrètes puisqu'il y a deux articles de
programmation sur lesquels on peut
commenter mais qui ne sont qu'une
approbation d'un programme global et
ensuite des articles qui sont des
articles législatifs je crois que nous
faisons un bon choix
la majorité de la commission en ne suant
pas le premier projet du gouvernement
ayant plutôt une liste fermée pour
l'instant des infractions pour
lesquelles pourra s'appliquer la
l'amende forfaitaire
délictuelle je crois que c'est important
pour une raison
bien sûr il y a une raison juridique que
le Conseil d'État a soulevé mais il y a
aussi une raison pratique c'est que
toutes vos équipes monsieur le ministre
qui seront en déplacement sur la voie
publique et qui auront la faculté
d'utiliser l'amende forfaitaire
des visuel auront un problème de
capacité mémorielles si on leur dit vous
avez le droit de le faire pour 500 et
pour 500 dédiés différents et il me
semble donc il vaut mieux se concentrer
sur une dizaine pour l'instant de délits
qui sont ni limitativement énumérés et
sur lesquels ils auront le savoir-faire
l'aide à la rédaction tout simplement de
la menthe de le procès verbalt d'amour
de manière que ce soit efficace
rapidement et si comme on peut le
supposer ça se révé efficace on pourra
faire une deuxième vague on peut entre
guillemets de catégorie d'infraction qui
pourront en être redevable
je crois aussi que la le développement
des assistants d'enquêtes c'est une
bonne mesure que ça complète en effet la
capacité des officiers de police
judiciaire et que d'ailleurs les autres
mesures qui simplifient le travail des
OPJ ne sont vraiment pas du luxe
notamment les habilitations plus rapides
et la possibilité de demander des actes
de pollution scientifique sans passer
par une procédure formaliste donc il me
semble que c'est un texte sur lequel la
Commission est très bien travaillé je
crois en très forte convergence avec
l'esprit du gouvernement
ce qui prouve que c'était un très bon
choix d'amener ce projet de loi au Sénat
en premier donc nous la pression
beaucoup simplement je veux terminer en
soulignant que nous sommes dans une
situation de tension à l'heure actuelle
sur le plan du moral dans les effectifs
de la police judiciaire que vous y
attachez une grande importance monsieur
le ministre mais nous suivons tous cette
affaire il me semble qu'il y a d'abord
une recommandation à faire qui est que
ça ne traîne plus trop et que la
décision formelle de réorganisation soit
prise et qu'elle soit bien concentrée
sur une refonte des moyens et une
centralisation des soutiens mais qui
n'affecte pas la liberté professionnelle
et la responsabilité des agents mais le
malaise il vient aussi il faut bien le
dire d'une situation de surcharge que
vous avez décrite mais aussi le
sentiment d'un succès assez fréquent du
fait de la complexification accrue de la
du code de procédure pénale qui entraîne
un certain nombre il faut bien dire de
mais de plantage parce que les pièges de
procédure qui sont dans ce code sont
vraiment trop nombreux donc si je si
j'ai une recommandation à faire au
gouvernement dans son ensemble et pas
seulement à vous monsieur le ministre
c'est que la refonte complète du code de
procédure pénale soit mené à bien le
plus vite possible par des autorités
juridiques juridiques indiscutables de
manière que les officiers de police
judiciaire puissent travailler avec un
bon outil donc encore notre approbation
la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme Durin
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
la loi d'orientation et programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur que nous
examinons aujourd'hui étant quelque
sorte un texte deux points
qualificatif par rapport à son volet
numérique qui est conséquent mais bien
parce qu'il s'agit de la deuxième
version de ce texte après celle qui nous
avait été présentées en pleine campagne
présidentielle cette deuxième version a
maigri de moitié m'apparaît dans
l'ensemble plus sage elle a été excursée
de ses dispositions relatives à
l'immigration par exemple l'immigration
fait bien partie des prérogatives du
ministère de l'Intérieur je remercie la
première ministre d'avoir choisi de ne
pas confondre causalité et corrélation
en ce qui concerne les thèmes de
l'immigration et de la délinquance mais
monsieur le ministre et je vais
peut-être en surprendre certains ce
n'est pas à ce stade le texte sécurité
le plus déséquilibré que nous ayons eu à
étudier au Parlement ces dernières
années cela tient à son architecture
cette lobe me comprend trois parties la
partie budgétaire la partie orientation
avec le
et la partie normative avec le reste du
projet de loi en ce qui concerne la
partie budgétaire le groupe socialiste
se félicite des moyens accordé au
ministère de l'Intérieur dans une
période où nos forces de l'ordre sont
soumises à une pression quotidienne dans
une société souvent décrite comme
confrontée à davantage de violence
notre groupe veut profiter de ce débat
pour exprimer à nouveau un soutien sans
réserve à nos forces de l'ordre police
gendarmerie police municipale qui ne
compte bien souvent ni leurs heures ni
leurs efforts pour assurer la
tranquillité nos concitoyens Nantes au
Creusot à Saint-Denis Dijon Besançon ou
ailleurs la plupart des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle s'étaient
engagée accordée davantage de moyens la
lutte contre l'insécurité les 15
milliards annoncés dans ce texte
constituent donc une bonne nouvelle et
nous ne ferons pas la fine bouche même
si nous serons vigilants sur
l'application de cette loop me dans les
années qui viennent dans un contexte
économique toujours incertain
en ce qui concerne la partie orientation
qui constitue en quelque sorte le mode
d'emploi de ces 15 milliards il y a une
cohérence dans le rapport annexé qui
nous est fourni on comprend la filiation
avec le Livre blanc de la sécurité et le
bobo de la sécurité la place octroyée au
numérique même si nous comprenons les
inquiétudes de certains agents échaudés
par les échecs passés nous semble
légitime si nous ne croyons pas dans le
solutionnisme technologique nous sommes
convaincus qu'il faut donner à la police
les moyens d'affronter la criminalité à
armes égales sur les moyens plus
classiques nous attendons d'être
rassurés sur la méthode notamment en ce
qui concerne les déploiements des
brigades de gendarmerie nous avons pris
bonne note des orientations annoncées en
ce qui concerne les rapports police
population comme sur la formation mais
nous pensons qu'il pourrait être fait
davantage nous avons en outre quelques
interrogations sur le caractère exact du
continuum de sécurité les associations
les associations d'élus aiment à
rappeler que les collectivités doivent
agir en complémentarité avec les forces
de l'ordre et non en substitution mon
collègue Usain Bourgy reviendra sur ce
point dans quelques instants comme
beaucoup de groupes nous profiterons du
rapport annexé pour proposer des
amendements sans surprise ce sera pour
nous l'occasion d'aborder la question de
la réforme de la police et de la place
de la police judiciaire qui suscite une
levée de bouclier massive dans des
plaises au DGPN en ce qui concerne
maintenant la partie normative je tiens
en premier lieu à saluer le travail des
rapporteurs j'ai lu ici ou là que le
Sénat avait durci le texte cela ne me
semble pas correspondre à la réalité sur
plusieurs articles messieurs les
rapporteurs ont tenté d'apporter des
éléments de cadrage je pense ici au
dépôt de plainte par visio à l'abandon
des ordonnances pour la radio aux
prévisions apportées aux précisions
apportées pour l'amende forfaitaire des
rituels par exemple notre groupe
comprend et partage par ailleurs la
volonté de rapporter des rapporteurs
d'aligner des sanctions pour violences
sur les élus sur celles risquées pour
des violences sur d'autres dépositaires
de l'autorité publique
pour autant le groupe socialiste
écologiste est républicain ne se
satisfait pas de ce projet de loi tel
que sortie de la commission des lois
nous défendrons dans ce débat nos
exigences sur plusieurs points qui nous
paraissent tes anciennes il s'agit des
amendes forfaitaire délictuelle de la
réponse au rang songiciel nous
formulerons aussi la proposition d'une
juridiction spécialisée dans les
violences sexuelles et sexistes infligés
aux femmes et aux enfants nous
proposerons également de revenir sur des
articles où la Commission à
effectivement durcit le texte je pense
ici au refus d'obtempérer et au rodéo
urbain je ne crois pas nous ne croyons
pas que sur ces sujets difficiles la
réponse réside dans un simple
durcissement de la punition sur ce point
comme sur l'ensemble de la loi je pense
que nous aurons une discussion
parlementaire sereine
si notre chambre n'a pas été renouvelée
au mois de juin soyez assurés monsieur
le ministre qu'elle est parfaitement
consciente de l'état du pays et de la
nécessité d'avoir un dial un dialogue
parlementaire constructif le Sénat était
déjà partisan du parlementarisme de fête
avant la majorité introuvable sortie des
urnes en 2022 nous ne doutons pas que
vous saurez y contribuer avec nous nous
aurons en tout cas cette nécessaire
prise en compte du Parlement dans sa
diversité au moment de décider de notre
vote merci chers collègues la parole est
à Madame Eliane assassy pour le groupe
CRCE
madame la Présidente
avec le monsieur le ministre
bon monsieur Sueur c'est quand vous
voulez là
[Rires]
madame madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de lofni a été annoncé donc lors des
conclusions du bobo de la sécurité en
2021 il s'inscrit dans la logique de la
loi dite de sécurité
globale de mars 2021 nous dont nous
demandons l'abrogation s'appuyant sur le
Livre blanc de la sécurité intérieure
publiée en novembre 2020 près de la
moitié des moyens prévus par le projet
de l'openy et dédié à la transformation
numérique alors loin de moi l'idée de
rejeter cette transformation mais ils me
semble que l'équilibre n'est pas
respecté au sens où la formation de nos
policiers aurait dû être elle aussi
aurait dû elle aussi pardon faire
l'objet d'un effort conséquent en termes
de moyens alors je sais bien que
certains ici ne veulent pas l'entendre
mais mon groupe c'est toujours toujours
refusé à stigmatiser nos forces de
l'ordre et il a toujours reconnu les
difficultés dans l'accomplissement de
leur mission mais nous portons l'idée
selon laquelle les dispositifs de
maintien de doivent reposer le plus
souvent possible sur la négociation le
dialogue et la pédagogie et non sur la
répression au risque d'aggraver le
sentiment de défiance envers la police
et une partie de la population
malgré vos affirmations monsieur le
ministre selon laquelle la locmi est un
levier de rapprochement avec les
citoyens force et de constater que c'est
le contraire d'une part les victimes
seront mises à distance par cette loi
ainsi les dépôts de plainte devraient se
faire en présentiel et non en ligne
chacune et chacun ici peut en comprendre
les raisons d'autre part le projet de
locmi s'éloigne de la coordination entre
police et justice en prenant le tour et
précis par la systématisation et la
simplification de la procédure en
simplifiant la procédure pénale sans
vouloir l'expliquer n'est-ce pas
considérer que nos agents sont
incapables de les comprendre de la
comprendre
on ne cesse de nous répéter qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'un texte sur la justice
mais au regard de ces dispositions nous
pouvons sérieusement en douter la loopy
en généralisant la menthe forfaitaire
forfaitaire des rituels à certains
délits privent les justiciers des
garanties fondamentales qu'offres la
procédure pénale elle délègue aux agents
de police une fonction qui relève en
principe de l'autorité judiciaire comme
la souligner la CNCDH mais également le
Conseil d'État dans son avis du 10 mars
dernier la lovni envisage également que
les EPG puissent procéder à des
constatations et des examens techniques
ou scientifiques sans réquisition
préalable éloignant alors les enquêteurs
du contrôle en temps réel du parquet ou
du juge d'instruction or il est
difficile d'accepter l'idée que la
police technique et scientifique puisse
s'auto saisir en outre un abaissement
des exigences dans le recrutement des
opéjes n'est pas souhaitable un officier
de police judiciaire dispose de pouvoir
coercitif dont on ne dispose pas un
agent de police judiciaire la
responsabilité nécessite
de même mettre en place la fonction
d'assistant de police et de gendarmerie
n'est pas un gage d'efficacité la
procédure pénale même son aspect le plus
infime nécessite vigilance et rigueur
mes chers collègues avec cette locmin
nous sommes face à une excusez-moi de
l'expression mcdonalisation de la
procédure pénale or servir le citoyen et
sa sécurité voilà le cœur battant du
métier de policier le projet de locmi
l'ignore pour nous proposer une vision
un peu fantasmée à savoir une police
hyper équipe équipée c'est le label
Robocop qui nous est proposé des
exosquelettes ou encore des policiers
des gendarmes et des pompiers augmenter
ne font pas de nos agents de police de
meilleures professionnels ce texte passe
à côté des véritables enjeux des métiers
de la sécurité publique nous souhaitons
une police qui met en oeuvre le
triptyque prévention dissuasion
répression une police non pas coupée du
citoyen mais une police de proximité
exemplaire et digne ce qui est
l'ambition portée par des milliers de
policiers et de policiers votre tâche au
gouvernement notre tâche au Parlement
c'est d'aider à restaurer une confiance
trop souvent perdue quelle politique
mettez-vous en place pour parler à la
jeunesse des quartiers populaires nous
dénonçons par ailleurs les partenariats
privilégiés avec des sociétés privées
dans la droite ligne du projet de
sécurité globale que la locmi envisage
un tel souhait traduit la volonté de
l'exécutif de se couper de la police
républicaine au profit du sécurité de
sécurité mercantile bien éloignée de
fonctions régaliennes de l'État enfin la
locmi et l'antichambre de la réforme à
venir portant la départementalisation de
la police judiciaire une
départementalisation synonyme
d'intrusion du pouvoir exécutif dans les
procédures pénales la colère s'exprime
fortement au sein de la magistrature
chez les avocats et comme nous l'avons
vu la semaine dernière chez les
enquêteurs de police judiciaires
monsieur le ministre notre société est
sous tension à la crise sociale est
ajouté les cris sanitaires et la guerre
sur notre continent la réalité de la
crise climatique et écologique est
incontournable l'insécurité globale et
la police se doit être une force
d'apaisement et non pas rajouter de
l'anxiété à l'anxiété cette difficile
équation je veux bien le reconnaître
entre prévention accompagnement et
protection est un défi votre loi et
votre approche ne peuvent en l'état le
relevé nous voterons donc contre ce
projet toit de l'opni et proposeront au
Sénat des voies alternatives même si
j'ai bien compris quel risque d'être
rejeté par nos rapporteurs je vous
remercie
merci madame la Présidente
la parole est à Madame Dominique Verrien
pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre je tiens tout d'abord à vous
dire que j'apprécie particulièrement les
développements de votre rapport annexé à
l'article 1 car nous demandons beaucoup
à nos policiers et à nos gendarmes mais
ils ont besoin de soutien et
d'accompagnement et dans ce rapport nous
trouvons tout ce dont nous rêvons pour
un meilleur fonctionnement de la police
de la gendarmerie et la meilleure prise
en charge des victimes
mes pardonnez-moi je ne suis pas sûr que
tout soit applicable sans avoir recours
à des modifications de la loi
modification que l'on ne trouve pas
forcément dans le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui je pense par
exemple aux évolutions nécessaires pour
assurer notre sécurité lors des grands
événements sportifs à venir ce n'est pas
grave l'intention est louable et cela
nous donnera l'occasion de nous revoir
prochainement revenons donc au texte sur
la police judiciaire d'abord un syndicat
bien connu communique souvent en disant
que le problème de la police c'est la
justice
mais c'est oublier que parfois le
problème de la justice c'est la police
et je n'incriminerai bien sûr pas les
policiers mais force est de constater
que la filière d'investigation n'attire
plus autant qu'avant et ses difficultés
de recrutement avec de nombreuses
équipes en sous-effectif on des
conséquences directes sur la qualité des
enquêtes et le délai de mise en oeuvre
de la réponse pénale et les stocks qui
se constituent dans les commissariats
sont autant d'affaires non traitées donc
de justice non rendu qui vont se
terminer trop souvent en déclaration
sans suite faute d'avoir les moyens de
les poursuivre laissant un sentiment
d'injustice au plaignant mais est-ce un
sentiment
en réponse ce texte prévoit une
facilitation de l'exercice des missions
d'investigation un renforcement de
l'efficacité de leur action une
formation initiale plus orientée vers
les métiers de l'investigation ainsi que
la création d'agents de police
judiciaires je salue également la
proposition de nos rapports Loïc Hervé
et Marc Philippe daubrais d'attribuer la
qualité d'agents de police judiciaire
aux élèves officiers de la Gendarmerie
nationale durant lorsque l'arrêté afin
qu'ils puissent constituer un renfort
appréciable durant leur stage en unité
territoriale
ces apports devraient outre permettre à
plus de dossiers d'être traité de mieux
accompagner les victimes mais attention
à certaines propositions du rapport
annexé car permettre à chacun et chacune
de déposer une plainte et d'en effectuer
le suivi en ligne avec un contact direct
par chat avec un policier ou un gendarme
ce sont de formidables idées mais est-ce
bien réaliste tant ces propositions
représentent un bon de géant par rapport
à la situation actuelle et je crains
quelques déceptions j'espère cependant
me tromper sur le cas particulier des
violences intra-familiales qui sont
devenus un contentieux de masse avec la
libération de la parole le rapport
prévoit un doublement du nombre
d'enquêteurs dédiés et le financement de
200 postes d'intervenants sociaux
en police et en gendarmerie
ces intervenants sociaux sont très
utiles et il est vrai que leur
financement posait trop souvent un
problème que vous proposez donc de
régler je salue aussi la création d'un
fichier de prévention des violences
intrafamilales afin de mesurer pour un
jour empêcher la réitération de faits de
violence et de prendre en compte les
signaux de dangerosité là aussi son
efficacité dépendra de la formation des
forces de l'ordre et de leur capacité à
distinguer les signaux faibles et
apprendre les bonnes décisions
rapidement un gendarme ne doit plus
hésiter à demander le retrait d'une arme
à feu d'un ami chasseur dans un contexte
de violence intrafamiliale
enfin les associations pourront
accompagner plus efficacement les femmes
victimes de violence en organisant le
dépôt de plainte dans leur locaux et en
signalant les faits dont elles ont
connaissance aux forces de l'ordre
j'imagine que ce dépôt de plainte se
fera par déplacement d'un officier ou
d'un agent de police judiciaire d'où
l'utilité de la création de ces derniers
toutes ces mesures vont dans le bon sens
et sont les bienvenus si elles sont
réellement appliquées je ne manquerai
pas de faire un suivi particulièrement
attentif de la mise en oeuvre de ces
mesures après avoir fait un état des
lieux dans le cadre de la mission que
m'a fait confié la première ministre sur
le sujet des violences intrafamiliales
sur le numérique enfin j'ai eu souvent
l'occasion de me pencher sur la
situation du numérique pour la justice
bien moins pour la police mais
heureusement je ne suis pas dépaysée
tant les problèmes sont similaires
d'ailleurs justice et police ont tout
intérêts à travailler et à concevoir
ensemble les outils transversaux
Cassiopée par exemple qui pénalise tant
de magistrats tant magistrat que
policier et gendarmes dans le cadre de
la procédure pénale numérique est un bon
exemple de cette nécessité d'un travail
concerté l'idée d'une grande agence du
numérique pour le ministère de
l'intérieur avec une double tête
gendarmerie police paraît donc
pertinente mais seulement si les leçons
de l'échec du projet scribe en partie dû
à une divergence de vision sur le
numérique entre police et gendarmerie
ont bien été tirés
enfin cela ne relève pas de la loi mais
peut-être faudrait-il aussi se
concentrer sur le plus urgent et sur ce
qui peut être réglé rapidement par
exemple certaines gendarmerie au hasard
dans l'Yonne ne sont toujours pas fibrés
et ne le seront pas avant dans le
meilleur des cas 2023 il est sans doute
possible d'accélérer les choses
hasard toujours je vous alerter sur ce
sujet par une récente question écrite
restez sans réponse à ce jour cet
exemple va un souligner l'importance du
maillage territorial maillage que vous
venez renforcer avec les nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie et les gendarmes
mobiles mieux équipés en plus grand
nombre ainsi que par le développement
des maisons France service
sur ce sujet d'ailleurs monsieur Emilie
monsieur le ministre ça me fait toujours
tiquer quand j'entends vos services
parler de création de maison France
services alors oui c'est bien une
création de nom oui mais j'entends
beaucoup notre préfet notamment par les
créations alors qu'en fait c'est souvent
une montée en compétence c'est vrai mais
de structures de maison de service au
public déjà existantes je pense qu'il y
a suffisamment à faire et que vous en
faites déjà beaucoup pour ne pas gommer
ce que vos prédécesseurs ont pu déjà
créer je dis d'autant plus facilement
que ça n'était pas ma famille politique
mais ça lui manque les maisons de
services au public existaient déjà en
définitive ce texte enrichi par le
travail de nos rapporteurs que je tiens
à saluer de nouvelles fois constitue une
bonne réponse aux problématiques que
nous connaissons sous réserve de sa
juste application mais vous pouvez
compter monsieur le ministre sur la
vigilance du Sénat à ce sujet en
conséquence le groupe Union centriste
votera ce texte
merci chers collègues
mes chers collègues voici le résultat du
scrutin pour l'élection d'un juge
suppléant à la Cour de Justice de la
République
nombre de votants
suffrages exprimé
261 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 131 bulletin blanc 27 bulletins
nul 0 Monsieur Gilbert Favreau donc
suppléant élu avec 261 voix
ce candidat ayant obtenu la majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés il est
proclamé juge suppléant à la Cour de
Justice de la République
Monsieur Gilbert Favreau va être appelé
à prêter devant le Sénat le serment
prévu par l'article 2 de la loi
organique du 23 novembre
1993 sur la Cour de Justice de la
République
je vais donner lecture de la formule du
serment je vous prie de bien vouloir
vous lever
à l'appel de votre nom et de répondre en
levant la main droite par les mots je le
jure voici la formule du serment
je jure et promet de bien et fidèlement
remplir mes fonctions de garder le
secret des délibérations et des votes et
de me conduire en tout comme un digne et
loyal magistrat
je le jure
acte est donné par le Sénat du serment
qui vient d'être prêté devant lui
[Applaudissements]
et nous reprenons le fil de la
discussion avec l'intervention de
Monsieur Stéphane Ravier
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je profite de la
tribu en cet assemblée pour manifester
mon opposition à votre politique sans
crainte d'être démunie d'être démis
pardon de mes fonctions cela au début
c'est un petit peu la même chose cela
n'a malheureusement pas été le cas
réservé à
Eric aérée cela n'a malheureusement pas
été le sort on va y arriver réservé à
ericarella directeur zonal de la police
judiciaire de Marseille limogé ce
vendredi connu chez nous pour son
professionnalisme et son intégrité vous
avez coupé la tête d'un géant et cela ne
vous a pas grandi et vous persistez
puisque dans la presse vous menacez le
sanction des policiers manifestants vous
n'aurez formez pas vous détruisez un
monument avec des méthodes expéditives
que des observateurs étrangers
n'auraient pas tort de qualifier
d'autoritaire et peu démocratique mais
revenons à ce projet de loi vous ne
radiquez pas les causes de l'insécurité
vous vous contentez d'en gérer les
conséquences on ne lit rien de la
nouvelle stratégie en vue de rompre avec
le délitement de l'autorité et
l'augmentation de l'insécurité le
contexte est pourtant très dégradé nous
restons sous la menace terroriste
incapable incapable de localiser et
d'expulser un imam islamiste au point
qu'il a dû s'expulser lui-même et
impuissance devant la recrudescence et
des rodé aux urbains et des refus
d'obtempérer mortels pour les agents et
les passants et on entend monter une
détestable petite musique venue du
walkistan dont les paroles affirment que
la police tue sans que ce texte
n’instaure de nouveau grand principe
pour la protéger la présomption de
légitime défense pour toutes les forces
de l'ordre faisant usage de leur arme
dans l'exercice de leur fonction
UTT un symbole fort vous l'avez refusé
de plus la police municipale n'a
semble-t-il pas sa place dans votre
continuum de sécurité elles sont
pourtant les dernières garantes de
l'ordre dans les communes reculées et
quasi systématiquement les prix moins
intervenantes sur le terrain c'est
totalement anachronique de parcourir ce
texte sans aucune mention à ces agents
municipaux il conviendrait pourtant de
leur accorder des compétences de police
judiciaire et de généraliser le port
d'armes de catégorie B1 enfin vous avez
évoqué en août la sur-représentation des
étrangers dans les statistiques de la
police et de la justice avec notamment
55% des délinquants interpellés à
Marseille qui sont étrangers nous
n'avons aucune traduction dans ce texte
du commencement d'un début de solution
pour y remédier vous qui aimez
décloisonner je pensais naïvement que
vous comprendriez l'utilité de ne pas
légiférer avec des œillères ce n'est pas
pour rien que le classement des villes
les plus sûrs du monde donnent
marseillais Nice derrière Bagdad et
Tripoli qui représentent respectivement
les villes d'Al-Qaïda et de daesh après
que l'insécurité aura gagné l'ensemble
du territoire urbain la répartition de
l'immigration dans les campagnes voulues
par Emmanuel Macron général généralisera
non pas douter le grand temps
sauvagement un chercheur a évolué a
évaluer le coût financier de cette
insécurité française à 69 milliards
d'euros par an un torrent de larmes et
de sang dans un gouffre financier ce
phénomène national débarrasser les
Français dans leur intégrité physique
dans leur prospérité dans leur cohésion
sachez à l'avenir monsieur le ministre
vous en souvenir et de ne plus vous
tromper de cible en limogène plutôt que
ceux qui la combattent merci Monsieur
ravier la parole est à Madame Marie
scarer pour le groupe RDSE
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues notre pays va être le
lieu de nombreux événements ces
prochaines années Jeux Olympiques et
coupe du monde de rugby qui s'ajouteront
au défi habituel de la sécurité publique
nous ne voulons pas revivre les
polémiques de mai dernier autour de
l'organisation de la finale de Ligue des
champions au Stade de France c'est pour
cela qu'il faut impérativement prévenir
tout risque de fiasco aussi je rejoins
la position de nos rapporteurs pour
l'essentiel ce texte va dans la bonne
direction et répond à un certain nombre
d'attentes du ministère de l'Intérieur
et des besoins de sécurité publique nous
saluons les annonce et les ambitions du
rapport et de la perspective budgétaire
outre l'adaptation au monde du numérique
il est tenu compte des problématiques de
l'ancrage local des forces de sécurité
cela nécessite évidemment des moyens du
point de vue du personnel et du matériel
nous y serons vigilants lors de l'examen
des prochaines budgets
et surtout ces nouvelles ressources
devront tenir compte de la spécificité
des enjeux locaux on pense souvent aux
zones urbanisées lorsqu'il est question
de sécurité publique mais le milieu
rural ne doit pas être oublié nous
saluons également les apports de notre
Commission concernant l'accessibilité
des personnes en situation de handicap
d'autant que la France accuse toujours
un retard en matière d'accessibilité
universelle en revanche un autre point
nous préoccupe très particulièrement
celui de la formation des personnels
concurrents à la sécurité intérieure du
pays si la formation initiale est
relativement étoffée il n'a n’est pas
toujours de même pour la formation
continue qui est trop souvent délaissée
au cours de la carrière il y a encore à
faire si nous souhaitons améliorer la
performance des différents services
les travaux en cours de la mission
d'information sur les moyens d'action et
les méthodes d'intervention de la police
de la gendarmerie nous révèle une marge
importante de progression de ce point de
vue nous émettons quelques réserves
quant à la disposition de l'article 9
qui assouplit les conditions requises
pour exercer les attributions attachées
à la qualité d'officier de police
judiciaire notamment en supprimant la
condition des trois années de service
bien sûr cela ne retirera rien à la
formation initiale de l'agent mais trois
années de pratique y seront enlevées
alors que chacun sait combien ces postes
sont exigeants et que l'expérience et le
pendant de la formation des agents un
policier ou un gendarme doté de
responsabilité notamment en matière
d'investigation doit être expérimentée
nous nous interrogeons aussi sur la
simplification de la procédure pénale le
rapport annexe le souligne il y a un
sujet autour de la complexité
procédurale de l'action pénale pour
autant nous croyons aussi que la
simplification ne doit pas accompagner
d'une dégradation de certains principes
fondamentaux l'encadrement procédural
donne un sa légitimité à l'action de
l'État en matière de répression c'est un
moyen pour écarter l'arbitraire et de ce
point de vue il ne saurait être question
de renoncer à des éléments de procédure
seulement parce que les policiers et les
gendarmes ne sont plus en capacité de
les respecter en revanche simplifié
notre droit jusqu'à renoncer à
l'intervention d'un juge ne saurait être
une réponse à un manque de moyens et de
formation dans nos services la
généralisation de la main de forfaitaire
délictuelle nous apparaissait comme une
fausse bonne idée dans la mesure où elle
participait à marquer un être culte de
l'action des juges comme du principe
fondamental d'individualisation des
peines je veux donc saluer la position
retenue par notre commission des lois
sur cette question en limitant très
fortement ce dispositif
je rajouterai un élément sur la récente
polémique déclenchée suite à la
proposition de réforme de l'APJ les
inquiétudes sont légitimes les experts
des expérimentations ont été menées
quels sont les résultats de ces
expérimentations nous aurions souhaité
en avoir connaissance afin de mieux nous
prononcer sur ce projet de loi si sur le
fond on pourrait y être favorable sur la
forme le manque de concertation aura été
pénalisant mais monsieur le ministre
vous avez fait pas plus tard qu'hier un
pas dans ce sens je conclurai un
évoquant un dernier sujet qui s'est
invité dans ce projet de loi suite à
l'adoption d'un article par notre
Commission visant notamment au
renforcement de la réponse pénale quant
aux violences faites aux élus ce sujet
est très préoccupant nous observons ces
dernières ces derniers mois une forte
recrudescence des incivilités et surtout
des agressions envers les élus locaux
nous avions déposé plusieurs amendements
reprenant différentes propositions de
loi déposées par mes collègues du groupe
RDSE Nathalie Delattre
Eric gold je regrette qu'ils aient été
pour la plupart des carrés irrecevables
en raison d'une approche restrictive du
périmètre de ce projet de loi nous
voulons redire notre mobilisation sur ce
sujet toutes ces remarques n'enlèvent
pas l'intérêt de ce projet de loi que
notre groupe votera dans sa quasi
majorité je vous remercie merci Madame
Carrère
la parole est à monsieur le président
Roger karucci pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre puisque la présidente assassy a
fait tout à l'heure référence cinémat
cinématographique sur Robocop moi je
penserai plutôt 40e rugissant oui
monsieur le ministre le film 41 où je
dis ça a exactement 40 ans il y a 82
comme vous si je puis me permettre et et
il est filmé avec un acteur formidable
Jacques Perrin qui avait 40 ans au
moment du film et cet acteur affronte
des lames de fond ben vous ministre de
l'Intérieur vous affrontez des lames de
fond
la lame de fond c'est la
course-poursuite entre l'État
les collectivités qui essayent d'assurer
la sécurité et d'autre part à
delinquance qui se renforce qui est de
plus en plus violente qui est de plus en
plus technique qui est de plus en plus
difficile à maîtriser et on a
l'impression depuis plusieurs années
nous avons ici voté beaucoup de textes
sur la sécurité on a l'impression qu'il
y a une course dont on n'est jamais
vainqueur parce que les délinquants
toujours plus de moyens parce que les
délinquants toujours plus de technique
et parce que nous respectons les règles
et les lois nous avons du mal à la
contrecarrer
et nous n'avons jamais réussi dans ce
pays à faire de la sécurité un droit
fondamental la sécurité n'est pas un
droit fondamental en France elle n'est
pas et elle n'a pas de qualité de
critères supra législatif en réalité
aucun citoyen ne peut opposer son droit
à la sécurité il y a une obligation de
moyens il n'y a pas une obligation de
résultat
et c'est en soi-même quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile alors je ne vais
pas revenir sur les excellents rapports
des excellents rapporteurs je ne vous
cacherai pas que naturellement bien
entendu et vous le savez nous allons
voter ce texte amendé par la commission
des lois
parce que je pense que peut-être pour la
première fois
l'état reprend la course
et l'État peut peut-être se donner si
naturellement de budget en budget on
respecte cette loi d'orientation peut
peut-être se donner les moyens de gagner
contre les délinquants à partir de là je
n'ai pas grand chose à vous dire à part
vous avez de la chance à 40 ans ministre
de l'Intérieur vous avez un texte qui
pour après tout est quand même un texte
qui fait large majorité et un texte qui
va marquer je pense que ça va marquer
parce que vous avez cranté un certain
nombre de sujets qui vont être
déterminants dans la lutte contre
l'insécurité
et à partir de là je n'ai plus grand
chose à vous dire sinon peut-être deux
trois observations première observation
monsieur le ministre vous ne le prendrez
pas mal
je pense que
vous aviez changé l'image du ministre de
l'Intérieur auprès des policiers
beaucoup de policiers beaucoup de
syndicats de police il y a 6 mois me
disait
ça bouge
on est content ça marche on a plus de
moyens plus d'équipements on est reconnu
et il faut reconnaître et j'en ai parlé
avec Marc Philippe faut reconnaître que
cette affaire de la police judiciaire
il faut trouver une solution vous avez
fait des propositions ces derniers jours
je pense que le rapporteur en fait il
faut que vous trouviez sincèrement une
solution parce que c'est pas seulement
l'affaire de la police judiciaire
c'est l'affaire de la police en général
et nous avons besoin de la police de la
République et vous avez besoin de la
police de la République il n'y a pas
d'état il n'y a pas de République sans
police sans police reconnue par les
citoyens comme étant leur police la
police du peuple la police de la
République et c'est pour cela que très
naturellement dans mon camp politique
jamais personne ne se permettrait de
critiquer l'action de la police ou de
tenir des propos qu'on a pu entendre
dans certains camps et j'admets bien
volontiers que ça n'est pas dans le
groupe communiste qu'il a dit tout à
l'heure et c'est pas de ce côté là que
les choses se disent il faut que
l'action de la police soit soutenue si
nous voulons avoir une chance que cette
sécurité qui est un droit premier pour
les citoyens soit aussi quelque chose
que chacun des citoyens s'approprient et
là vous avez un rôle essentiel à jouer
le deuxième élément est dans le temps
qui m'est imparti j'arrêterai là
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit
vous-même tout à l'heure il y aura
monsieur Dupont-Moretti à qui je ne
doute pas vous parler régulièrement qui
viendra avec un texte sur les milieux
sur les états généraux de la justice etc
franchement
depuis des années j'entends dire police
justice les policiers disent les
magistrats ne nous suivent pas donc
c'est décourageant les magistrats disent
oui mais la police parfois on a un côté
un peu on peut se parler quoi à Caen des
états généraux de la police et de la
justice pas seulement entre les deux
ministres entre tous les syndicats tous
les acteurs par pitié les Français
méritent bien ça
président
la parole est à Monsieur Dany Wattebled
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Messi le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
notre pays les homicides sont en hausse
les coûts ainsi que les villes en
sexuelles connaissent une très forte
augmentation
dressé par le ministère de l'Intérieur
pour la 2020 doivent nous alarmer des
vacances quotidiens ou grandes
criminalité l'enjeu de la sécurité de
notre pays est majeur pour nos
concitoyens
le président Macron avait promis lors de
sa réélection de renforcer la présence
des forces de l'ordre sur le terrain
le projet de loi il trace le chemin pour
y parvenir d'ici à 2027 il met les
moyens budget dans la voiture de 20% de
plus de 20%
bien que cette histoire soit jugée pour
crédible par le Conseil d'État il est
indispensable de juguler la progression
de la sécurité
elle brise la vie de certains de
concitoyens et empoisonnent les autres
la sécurité met en péril le pacte
républicain
elle nuit également au développement de
notre économie et au rayonnement de
notre pays la France s'apprête en outre
à accueillir de grands événements
c'est des raisons supplémentaires pour
que les forces de l'ordre disposent de
moyens d'assurer leur de public
notre groupe est en faveur de cette
augmentation de budget
parallèlement à celui de la justice
l'État doit en mesure d'assurer ces
missions en galiennes il s'agit en effet
en effet de ces missions les plus
essentielles
les fonds prévus pour les forces de
l'ordre serviront notamment à augmenter
les effectifs c'est une très bonne chose
je souhaiterais plus particulièrement
évoquer deux sujets concernant les
effectifs le premier est celui du zonage
les interventions en zone gendarmerie il
me semble très important que les forces
de l'ordre connaissent le terrain les
habitants pourra jouer au mieux au plus
près de leur caserne le second concerne
la police judiciaire une réforme sans
doute nécessaire mais semble
indispensable que ces agents conservent
leurs capacité d'enquête très
spécifiques et nous y serons attentifs
la problématique des effectifs ne doit
pas par ailleurs masquer celle des
équipements et des installations
vétustes il est grand temps d’inversé
tendance et de nous orienter jusqu'à le
cas c'est parti pour le rapport
annexieux au projet de loi prend en
compte cette problématique nous
seulement également attentifs à la mise
en œuvre des mesures annoncées
au-delà des aspects pragmatiques du
rapport et des deux premiers articles le
projet de loi contient plusieurs
dispositions de procédures pénales
l'été notamment question de généraliser
la posture d'amande forfaitaire à toutes
les infractions punies dans
l'emprisonnement d'au moins d'un an
maximum
le Conseil d'État indiqué dans son avis
qu'une telle disposition fut rentrée
dans ce périmètre plus de 3400
infractions la solution retenue par la
commission nous paraît plus sage une
dizaine d'infractions supplémentaires
pourront désormais faire le vieux de
cette procédure notre groupe est
satisfait de ce ciblage beaucoup plus
précis
nous sommes inquiets de constater que
les taux de mouvement de ses amendes
forfaitaire est mort
pour usage stupéfiants faire de lance de
cette procédure le taux était inférieur
à 50% en 2021 dans ces conditions il
nous paraît important d'améliorer sur le
courant de cet amende
le texte prévoit également la création
de la fonction décision d'enquête ce
personnage sera chargé de réaliser de
leurs tâches administratives qui
éloignent les policiers du terrain
un monde forfaitaire
sont donc deux des symptômes d'un mal
plus profond de 2008 à 2022 le code de
procédure pénal est passé de 1700
articles à 2400 articles la
complexification des procédures rend
plus difficile le travail des policiers
des magistrats et des profils du droit
cette complexification est également
porteuse de risque pour nos concitoyens
qu'ils soient mis en cause ou victime
l'inflation normative de la juguler les
procédures doivent simplifié la fusion
des cadres d'enquêtes pourrait
contribuer les états généraux de la
Justice ont rappelé l'année de conduire
une telle étude d'impact sur la
faisabilité et l'opportunité de fusion
il faut il procès sans attendre les
mesures continuent dans ce projet de loi
sont nécessaires notre groupe comme
beaucoup dans cette hémicycle soutiendra
son adoption ne reçoit demande une
action forte de l'État pour lutter
contre la sécurité ce texte y contribue
mais il faudra continuer à agir
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Guy benaroche pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire
chers collègues
l'avenir le rôle du ministère de
l'Intérieur sont d'organisation ses
moyens sont des sujets au cœur de notre
pack républicain de notre organisation
sociale de la protection des citoyens du
respect des droits de justiciable je ne
surprendrai personne si j'exprime ici au
nom de mon groupe les craintes que les
dispositions présentes dans ce projet
suscitent un mélange de Big Bowers
watching you et des meilleurs passages
de 84 d'Orwell et du pire de Robocop
mystery shopper policier augmenter robot
d'accueil drone aux frontières
numérisation à outrance cela alors où
l'électroniste touche une immense partie
de nos citoyens et où les territoires se
sortent de plus en plus éloignés de
l'accès à un humain du service public
nous nous devons vous tous chers
collègues mon groupe et moi de mettre en
action sans sobriété notre énergie et
notre intelligence collective pour ce
projet de loi nous avons donc voulu être
une force de proposition puisque le
ministre le rappelait hier dans sa
lettre envoyée à l'ensemble de la PJ ça
porte est ouverte à toutes les
propositions
nous propositions notre vision sont
issues d'une réelle réflexion
d'équilibre et pourraient se décliner en
deux éléments principaux le premier ne
vous étonnera pas monsieur le ministre
nous n'avons pas la même vision de la
police de la sécurité de la protection
du matière de l'ordre de la tranquillité
publique que celle que vous exposez est
défendez dans cette loi et ce rapport
mais nous ne partageons pas non plus la
position que nous trouvons attentiste
des rapporteurs et de la majorité un
exemple frappant est suivi de la mode
forfaitaire à laquelle nous sommes
opposés non seulement cet outil qu'on
est jusqu'à présent une application
territoriale disparate hétérogène
oserais-je dire éminemment concentré sur
certains quartiers mais surtout de plus
en plus cette rupture de traitement
territorial la volonté du gouvernement
de l'État légèrement restreint par la
commission sans aucune réalité de son
efficacité de son efficience actuelle
est un pas de plus dans l'éloignement du
juge
ce texte assis se fait l'écho des pires
positionnements qui voudraient que la
justice garote de l'application du droit
soit un frein aux forces de l'ordre
cela nous amène au second élément
essentiel dont je parlais c'est que nous
demandons que les femmes et les hommes
dans le rôle est d'assurer notre
sécurité et notre tranquillité soit
traitée avec humanité avec respect avec
considération clairement nous
considérons que les conditions de
travail de nos forces de l'ordre ne sont
pas au niveau des services que nous
attendons d'eux nous devons veiller à
diminuer leur souffrance au travail en
rendant à leur métier le sens qu'ils ont
perdu notre soutien aux agents de l'État
doit reposer sur la réalité retrouvée
d'exercer un métier avec et pour leurs
concitoyens
le besoin de sécurité des citoyens porte
aussi sur la transparence de l'action de
la police une meilleure gestion des
dérives parfois violentes une nouvelle
vision de l'IGPN mais aussi sur la
transparence des données de la police de
leur publication de leur transmission
aux élus aux autres le besoin de
sécurité des citoyens portent aussi sur
la gestion des risques incendies
amplifiés par l'inaction climatique du
gouvernement condamné à plusieurs
reprises nous proposerons des
améliorations sur ce sujet des services
incendie le besoin de sécurité des
citoyens porte aussi sur leur
environnement c'est pour soit nous
tracerons aussi des pistes pour le
développement d'une police
environnementale le besoin des citoyens
c'est aussi que le rapport annexe ce que
le rapport annexe s'appelle pudiquement
la transparence et l'exemplarité des
forces de l'ordre nous ferons de
nombreuses propositions sur le sujet
afin de renouer la confiance que les
citoyens doivent avoir dans leur force
de l'ordre
nous vous remercions d'avance de ne pas
faire d'amalgame à des faiurements
politiques de nos positions avec des
supposés positionnements Antipolis ou
anti-publicains tout au contraire nous
prétendrons et nous chercherons à vous
démontrer que nous propositions sont
plus protectrices non seulement pour les
citoyens mais aussi pour tous les
personnels des forces de l'ordre tant
physiquement que mentalement monsieur le
ministre monsieur les rapporteurs nous
ne voulant pas de drones nos frontières
et du tout surveillance dans la
politique migratoire y compris à
l'intérieur de nos frontières
européennes nous voulons une réelle
réflexion sur des mouvements migratoires
au niveau européen mais aussi une
refonte de nos politiques d'accueil nous
ne voulons pas d'une réforme de la
police judiciaire qui déstabiliserait la
dépendance du travail des magistrats
d'un projet qui entraîne le risque d'un
affaiblissement de la lutte contre le
grand banditisme en faisant perdre à
l'apaisie sa spécialisation en
rattachant le service de l'APG au ddpn
en établissement des liens forts entre
ceci et les préfets ce projet génère une
confusion entre le pouvoir judiciaire
administratif nous voulons une
sanctuarisation des moyens propres de sa
spécificité une sanctuarisation de
l'accès à la qualification d'OPJ loi de
sa dilution dans les autres formes de
sécurité loin d'une marginalisation des
parquets dans la définition de la
politique pénale
nous ne voulons pas vider les
commissariats juste pour mettre du bleu
dans la rue et faire du chiffre via des
amendes forfaitaire nous voulons une
réelle police de proximité pacificatrice
liée à son territoire nous devons pas de
LBD de drone de lacrymo de la technique
Lana sous d'autres techniques
d'interpellation dangereuses dans les
doctrines de maintien de l'homme et de
contrôle de la population depuis bord
d'élection j'observe parfois une
surprise souvent avec les froid la
dérive autoritaire de certains textes la
sécurité l'enjeu de tous mais les
dérives sécuritaires sont toujours venir
des mêmes monsieur le ministre c'est
pourquoi nous proposons l'expression de
notre vision par un grand nombre
d'amendements que nous allons discuter
et dans le sort cellera notre position
finale vis-à-vis de ce texte
merci Monsieur benaroche la parole est à
Monsieur scène Bourgi pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues le projet de loi qui
nous est proposé à au moins deux vertus
la première c'est celle de répondre à
une demande ancienne visant à doter nos
services de police et de gendarmerie des
moyens humains et matériels à la hauteur
des missions qui leur sont confiées la
seconde vertu de ce projet d'être
ambitieux avec l'annonce de moyens et
d'objectifs conséquents ces deux vertus
étant relevés et saluées je veux
monsieur le ministre me focaliser sur
les sujets qui méritent un peu plus
d'engagement et de précisions de votre
part si votre projet de loi est le
rapport annexé liste les grandes
orientations et les grandes trajectoires
cela manque parfois de précision et de
précision chiffrée en particulier nous
formons le vœu que le débat
parlementaire nous permettre de répondre
à ces attentes pour sortir des
indications parfois vagues et floues
vous avez élaboré votre doctrine en
matière de sécurité à partir du Livre
blanc de la sécurité intérieure et du
Beauvau de la sécurité à l'occasion de
l'élaboration de ce continuum de
sécurité vous avez voulu établir un
partenariat renforcé avec les communes
en matière de lutte contre l'insécurité
or monsieur le ministre les maires sont
de plus en plus nombreux à déchanter en
effet lorsqu'il souhaite s'équiper en
caméra de vidéo surveillance par exemple
et qu'il sollicite la préfecture pour
obtenir un confinement il leur est
répondu que l'enveloppe n'a pas évolué
or depuis les dernières élections
municipales il y a de plus en plus de
communes qui souhaitent s'équiper de
caméras de vidéosurveillance l'enveloppe
à louer aux préfectures n'a pas augmenté
lorsque ces mêmes mères prennent à leur
compte les travaux d'aménagement de
locaux de gendarmerie et de police c'est
le cas dans l'Hérault par exemple à
Frontignan ces bureaux se trouvent au
bout de quelques années malheureusement
déserté avec les policiers qui sont
transférés dans la commune voisine celle
de set en particulier dès lors les mers
sont de plus en plus nombreux à
s'interroger à nous interroger sur ces
réalités qu'ils vivent ils ont le
sentiment que le partenariat que vous
leur avez proposé parfois déséquilibré
on leur défaveur c'est la raison pour
laquelle beaucoup d'entre eux ont
accueilli avec circonspection et même
prudence l'annonce de la création de 200
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie ils
craignent une mise en concurrence entre
les territoires ceux qui ont les moyens
de mettre à disposition des locaux et
les autres ils craignent de financer de
locaux et de ne pas avoir le service
attendu par les administrés à l'arrivée
qu'avez-vous à leur dire monsieur le
ministre car ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir parfois conclu avec l'État un
contrat Léonard en matière de sécurité
beaucoup de maires sont confrontés à la
multiplication des infractions en
matière de circulation de stationnement
dans les grands centres urbains les
moyens techniques sont désormais
disponibles ça s'appelle la pie
lecture automatiser des plaques
d'immatriculation ces outils permettent
un contrôle efficace et régulier des
flux importants de véhicules néanmoins
en raison du cadre réglementaire vous le
savez monsieur le ministre le chant
d'utilisation des systèmes lapis reste
limités c'est pourquoi dans le respect
des règles de protection des données
personnelles il est impératives de faire
évoluer la réglementation pour lutter
plus efficacement permettre aux maires
permettre aux présidents
d'intercommunalité de lutter plus
efficacement contre le stationnement
gênant sur les places réservées au PMR
contre le stationnement gênant sur les
plateformes des tramways contre le
stationnement gênant sur les pistes
cyclables qui malheureusement
occasionnent souvent des accidents
corporels et parfois des accidents
mortels plusieurs maires de grandes
villes vous ont écrit en ce sens c'est
le cas de Michael Lafosse mère de la
ville de Montpellier ils attendent une
réponse de votre part concernant
l'évolution réglementaire ce n'est pas
du domaine législatif mais je me permets
de le préciser ici monsieur le ministre
vous avez annoncé votre volonté de
doubler les effectifs en matière de
police et de gendarmerie sur le terrain
vous souscrivons tous à cet objectif
mais si l'objectif tatin il restera
néanmoins la question du traitement la
création du traitement des procédures
d'instraction qui seront constatées dès
lors le risque est réel pour ne pas dire
certains monsieur le ministre de voir le
stock de procédure en souffrance
augmentée comment appréhendez-vous cette
situation et comment comptez-vous faire
pour indiquer cette probabilité vous
souhaitez enfin permettre la prise de
plainte et la déposition par le recours
à la visioconférence pourquoi pas ce qui
compte ce n'est pas la manière dont on
dépose plainte pré plainte
visioconférence ce qui compte c'est que
le plaignant soit informé tout au long
de la procédure et en la main c'est la
matière les marges de projection de
progression et de projection sont
réelles et sérieuses au moment de
conclure mon intervention le ministre je
voudrais réitérer au nom du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
l'intérêt que nous portons juridictions
spécialisées en matière de violence
conjugale et intrafamidale peut-être que
le débat vous permettra de nous dire
votre sentiment à la question ce projet
étant expurger des éléments clivant mais
sur le ministre nous formons le vol que
vous puissiez faire un pas envers nous
afin de témoigner la considération que
nous avons tous pour les gendarmes et
les policiers et l'intérêt que nous
portons à la sécurité des Françaises et
des Français je vous remercie si chers
collègues
la parole est à Monsieur philippe
Dominati pour le groupe des Républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
après avoir écouté mes différents
collègues de cette assemblée monsieur le
ministre je peux vous dire qu'il y a un
premier succès c'est que rarement une
loi a été aussi attendue et apportait
aussi d'intérêt sur toutes les bancs de
cet assemblée et pourtant la gestion n'a
pas été facile parce que dans le premier
quinquennat nous avons eu le sentiment
que la mission sécurité n'était pas une
priorité du gouvernement et du président
de la République la mission n'a pas été
facile parce que
en réalité vous avez évoqué la crise du
terrorisme dans cette horrible l'année
2015 mais vous êtes le 7e ministre de
l'Intérieur en 7 ans et sur une période
où je prends le dernier quinquennat et
l'avant dernier quinquennat et le
dernier quinquennat donc vous êtes le 7e
ministre de l'Intérieur en 7 ans c'est
pour dire que pour les pouvoirs publics
malgré la crise du terrorisme ce
ministère méritait des réformes méritait
une attention particulière et en réalité
on a géré pendant quelques années une
succession de crise une succession de
crise qui se sont manifestées par les
agents de l'État à des fréquences de
plus en plus régulières ça nous amenait
évidemment
normalement à au Livre blanc
a été suivi par les rencontres de
Beauvau une première version de la loop
me en marche 2022 et une seconde version
aujourd'hui et cette seconde version
effectivement c'est un intérêt
particulier parce que nous sommes au
début d'une mandature et que vous avez
su probablement attiré l'attention du
chef de l'État sur la nécessité de
recentrer la mission sécurité au cœur du
débat en ce début de mandature alors
en ces temps
quelle est l'effort pour ma part je
m'arrêterai surtout à l'article 2 de
cette loi d'orientation c'est-à-dire
l'effort financier vous l'avez souligné
tout à l'heure il y a une option
l'option en 2009
2 milliards 500 millions pour 5 ans dans
la loopnie c'est 6 fois plus j'ai essayé
de faire c'est pas tout à fait simple le
périmètre à le périmètre constant sur
les deux dernières sur deux séquences de
5 ans c'est-à-dire
2013-2017 les forces financier les
crédits paiement avaient augmenté de 12%
de 2018 à 2022 de créer dit de paiement
avait augmenté de 17%. c'est dire que
effectivement l'effort financier pour
les 5 ans à venir d'autant que la
principale est le principal effort sera
fait au cours du budget 2023 et plus que
satisfaisant puisque ce sera de l'ordre
de 22%. ça c'est pour l'aspect financier
l'enveloppe puis financière cette
locmire répond à deux principales
par revendication mais nécessité la
première c'est celle de répondre à la
révolution numérique l'effort est
important c'est une véritable
modernisation du ministère et des agents
de sécurité sur le terrain la deuxième
réforme c'est de doubler les effectifs
sur le terrain effectivement comme ça a
été dit par de nombreux collègues le
doublement des effectifs sur le terrain
ne doit pas se faire évidemment au
détriment du fonctionnement et de
l'investissement c'est la dérive que
nous avons constaté au Sénat au cours de
ces dernières années qui a été redressée
notamment grâce au crédit de relance du
covid et que vous avez sécurisé dans
cette loi de programmation du ministère
de l'intérieur c'est un ministère où il
n'est pas simple de faire des réformes
en réalité il y en a pas eu depuis la
crise du terrorisme en vrai si il y en a
eu une celle du temps de travail celle
du temps de travail le vendredi fort ça
occupait le ministère pendant cinq ans à
peu près vous avez annoncé à la fin du
quinquennat précédent qu'effectivement
ça avait été abandonné mais ça avait été
initié par Bernard Cazeneuve c'était
normalement une bombe dessinée à
l'alternance qui devait exploser puis
finalement ça s'est pas produit comme
prévu donc c'était la seule réforme qui
a eu ces dernières années concernant ce
ministère il est en ce moment la réforme
de la PJ la réforme de la PJ elle est
pas simple à appréhender parce
qu'effectivement comme tout le monde on
écoute les inquiétudes il y a des
inquiétudes sur le département 4G il y a
des inquiétudes sur le quantitatif par
rapport aux qualitatifs mais pour autant
elle est initiée par le directeur
général de la police judiciaire qui a
passé je crois 29 ans dans cette
institution et elle semble en partie
répondre effectivement la nécessité
d'incarner de nouveau par une seule
personne dans un lieu précis la fonction
policière et enfin il y a une réforme
qui a pas du tout été abordée qui est
annoncée gouvernement par gouvernement
régulièrement mais si elle a disparité
qu'il y a entre la police nationale et
la préfecture de police le cœur je
dirais du pays ça a été annoncé nous
avons eu monsieur casterner et Monsieur
Nunez devant le Parlement qui avait dit
que ça serait l'une des réformes clés et
puis finalement au fur et à mesure on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a cette disparité il
n'y a aucun dans cette loi d'orientation
concernant le cœur du pays coeur du pays
où toutes les sensibilités politiques il
y a quelques années en tant qu'élus
parisien je tiens de souligner était
plutôt pour la défense de la police
nationale Bertrand Delanoë avait annoncé
qu'il souhaitait que ça reste comme ça
et maintenant toutes les sensibilités
politiques sont pour une police
municipale on en a beaucoup parlé mais
il n'y a strictement rien sur ce sujet
monsieur le ministre un début continuer
dans les réformes de ce ministère
puisque c'est une nécessité beaucoup
trop de retard a été pris merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur Henri
Leroy pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
buffet
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
voilà une réforme qui va dans le bon
sens
en tant que partie prenante comme
parlementaire très engagé pour la
sécurité de nos campus de nos
compatriotes c'est naturellement que je
voterai cette loi cette locmie et c'est
suffisamment rare pour être souligné
correspond aux espoirs des forces de
sécurité intérieure
aux attentes des élus locaux et
nationaux qui a vécu l'occasion de
s'exprimer notamment lors des nombreuses
séances du bobo de la sécurité je vous
l'ai dit en connaissance de cause
pourrait voir participer activement au
titre du Sénat avec notre collègue
Jérôme Murat
notre mission consiste à contrôler
l'action du gouvernement un participer à
la mairie Roncière de la loi pour me
permettrait monsieur le ministre donc de
formuler deux réserves la première
relève de la prudence cette loi est le
fruit d'un long travail d'analyse et de
concertation nous en convenons tous
mais je vous demande ici solennellement
de veiller à son application
trop de textes votez reste l'être morte
faute de décret d'applications pris dans
un délai raisonnable mais surtout de
suivi concret sur le terrain et vous
êtes un homme de terrain
ma deuxième réserve porte sur le contenu
du texte lors de nos échanges en
audition par la commission des lois j'ai
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer à ce sujet
certes vous engagez judicieusement
la départementalisation de la police
nationale mais vous oubliez l'idée qui
était pourtant présent dans le bobo de
la sécurité de revoir la répartition
territoriale des forces de sécurité
intérieure c'est pourtant une attente
forte qui relève de la logique
temporelle tant de certains élus que de
nombreux acteurs silencieux du terrain
la répartition actuelle date du siècle
dernier depuis la délinquance et la
criminalité ne sont plus du tout les
mêmes et dans tous les domaines
d'appréciation concrètement cela
consiste en une nouvelle répartition
optimale des forces de sécurité
intérieure sur le territoire on étroite
collaboration avec les maires en vue de
faire face à l'hydre du 21e siècle qui
est devenu la délinquance dans notre
pays
mais alors pourquoi un tel renoncement
pour des raisons qui ne peuvent qu'être
à contre-pied de l'intérêt général
pour semblerait-il apaiser des craintes
corporatives d'intérêt plutôt
particulier voir sectoriel
vous avez renoncé parce que comme le
font trop souvent de nombreux décideurs
vous avez vraisemblablement cédé et
c'est mon opinion à la pression
syndicale monsieur le ministre notre
devoir à tous et d'assurer la sécurité
des Français de projeter les forces de
sécurité intérieure dans l'avenir la
situation est grave très grave trop de
territoires sont des territoires perdus
des territoires délaissés des
territoires sacrifiés de la République
dorénavant l'incivilité la délinquance
le crime la barbarie frappe partout y
compris dans cette France rurale et
périphérique cette douce France
autrefois épargnée
prendre des mesures justifices s'avère
par voie difficile car cela implique de
combattre les lobbys et les habitudes et
vous y êtes en plein dedans
mais c'est aussi à cela qu'on mesure la
pertinence et l'importance d'une réforme
montrez monsieur le ministre que comme
vos idées prédécesseurs Pierre Joxe et
Charles Pasqua votre détermination ne
s'arrête pas des attributions
matérielles techniques logistique et
humaine elle intègre dans la notion elle
intègre aussi la notion de stratégie
organisationnelles et fonctionnelle vous
le savez parfaitement monsieur le
ministre la répartition territoriale est
vraisemblablement l'une des clés
essentielle de cette très attendue
l'opmée la repoussée c'est peut-être
renoncée à l'espoir de voir les forces
de sécurité intérieure prendre le dessus
définitivement sur la délinquance et sur
la criminalité en France nous restons
pas dans le fond du panier derrière le
Mexique ou la Malaisie dans le
classement des pays basés sur l'indice
de sécurité moyen d'un BO cette loi est
un premier grand pas ne vous y arrêtez
pas
nous le devons à nos concitoyens nous le
devons à nos forces de sécurité comme
nous le devons à nos élus de première
ligne où nos valeurs Omer je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
la discussion générale éclose monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole pour
répondre aux orateurs
merci madame la Présidente je vais
essayer en effet de répondre aux
orateurs en les remerciant très
sincèrement de
leurs critiques mais aussi de leur
encouragement j'ai donc noté un soutien
si j'ose dire de la majorité sénatoriale
du Sénat y compris de ces groupes comme
le RDSE j'ai bien compris le groupe de
Monsieur Malhuret j'ai compris que
groupe socialiste interrogatif et
souhaitez que nous allions vers un sens
d'écoute je voulais vous dire que
c'était vraiment la position du
gouvernement et on aura l'occasion
d'avoir un débat je l'espère le plus
intéressant possible et j'ai compris que
c'était plutôt négatif de la part du
groupe communiste et du groupe
représentant le groupe écologiste mais
je voudrais ici vous dire que si on aura
des des débats je veux je veux essayer
de vous convaincre
j'espère que
pour ce débat intellectuel j'en suis sûr
que l'essence attendre interlocuteur
alors beaucoup de choses ont été dites
le soulignant notamment soit des
interrogations des amendements
permettront d'y revenir plus largement
soit des manques que vous avez évoqués
dans ce texte qui réessaie de résoudre
un paradoxe puisque le Parlement demande
des textes de plus en plus courts et
puis évidemment quand on traite pas
l'intégralité du champ politique
publique on dit mais c'est pas assez
long ouais très bien je veux bien
répondre à ces interrogations
de magiciens peut-être aux deux
rapporteurs d'abord dont je remercie le
travail mais c'est un travail
c'est-à-dire continuum puisque en
travaillant ensemble sur la loi sécurité
globale
finalement j'entends deux interrogations
de la part des rapporteurs le premier du
rapporteur de Bresse sur la plainte en
visio qui recoupe un certain nombre de
questions sur le numérique la distance
il est bien évident d'abord que pour le
ministreur que je suis n'est pas
question de remplacer à 100% le réel par
le visio ou par le numérique je suis
très attentif et je voudrais oui aux
amendements du groupe notamment
socialiste me semble-t-il qui évoquait
la possibilité de toujours laisser une
possibilité papier concret il sera
adopté avec l'enthousiasme du ministre
de l'intérieur c'est ce que j'ai fait
lorsqu'on a fait l'impôt à la source
ensemble c'est ce que nous faisons quand
nous faisons la hyprocuration il y a
toujours évidemment un accès en même
temps au monde papier au monde réel pour
l'utiliser comme vous l'avez dit donc je
veux dire au rapporteur de Brest pour
l'avoir
évoqué avec lui en étant un peu surpris
de son amendement pour faire très vite
nous permettons aujourd'hui par la loi
que vous voterez que demain nous
pourrons faire des plaintes en visio
vous prendrez un rendez-vous avec un
officier de police judiciaire qui soit
gendarme qui soit policier et vous
pourrez déposer votre plainte de votre
ordinateur et ainsi ne pas vous déplacer
au commissariat de la brigade de
gendarmerie
c'est quelque chose de très important
parce que aujourd'hui plus personne ne
comprend qu'il doit passer deux à trois
heures dans un commissariat pour déposer
une plainte que l'on peut qualifier de
véniel je me suis fait
dégrader ma mauvais véhicule je dois le
faire absolument pour les assurances
parce que c'est peut-être un véhicule
professionnel si nous allons ensemble
dans un commissariat que vous connaissez
toutes et tous pour le visiter plein de
fois en allant voir les services de
police on tombe sur des gens qui
attendent depuis une heure et demie deux
heures parce qu'il faut absolument
qu'avant qui repartent demain matin
parfois c'est des commerciaux parfois
c'est des gens qu'on les horaires
atypiques et donc très courageux
l'attente deux heures d'avoir un
policier en face de soi c'est pas une
police moderne pardon de le dire au
moment où on paye ses impôts de façon
numérique où on peut commander y compris
on fait parfois de la médecine de toute
façon numérique la police serait donc le
seul endroit au monde où le papier
serait toujours imprimé et le
commissariat ressemblant à Gérard Jugnot
dans opino simple flic je pense que il
faut que nous acceptions la
modernisation d'une grande
administration parce que le ministère de
l'intérieur c'est avant tout une grande
administration avant de l'administration
de force républicaine alors aujourd'hui
il y a déjà des pré plaintes en ligne
elles ne sont possibles que pour les
atteintes au bien
la prepinte en ligne mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs c'est 50% des plaintes que
va évoquer le policier ou le gendarme et
notamment le policier dans les zones les
plus urbaines ça marche on n'est pas
obligé dans une organisation normale de
pouvoir se dire que tout le monde doit
passer encore physiquement au
commissariat ou à brigade de gendarmerie
il faut passer de la pré plainte en
ligne à la plainte en ligne en laissant
le choix à l'interlocuteur s'il veut
venir physiquement évoquer son sujet ou
s'il veut le faire de manière numérique
et personne ne comprend encore une fois
qu'on demande une demi-journée de congé
à quelqu'un pour aller déposer une
plainte lorsque son vélo
je prends l'exemple d'un commissariat
parisien que j'ai visité il y a pas plus
tard que quelques jours où la dame qui
attendait la gueule me dit je me suis
fait voler mon Vélib est-ce qu'elle doit
attendre une faire une demi-journée de
congés c'était le cas de la dame pour
aller déposer plainte pour son Vélib
aujourd'hui l'administration parisienne
ce qui est bien logique donc chacun
comprend l'intérêt quand même sur
certaines plaintes de ne pas encombrer
les pouvoirs les services de police mais
en même temps de libérer la vie de nos
citoyens et de concentrer les plaintes
les plus graves notamment les attentes
aux personnes notamment les violences
intra familiales qui demandent beaucoup
de temps évidemment et d'écoute pour pas
se dire que il y a un travail
si je veux dire plus rapide à faire que
sont les dépôts de plainte lambda on va
dire ça comme ça vous recevez des des
mail un fishing qui vous demande se
faisant passer pour un petit cousines de
l'argent envoyé dans un pays étranger
faut-il aller passer trois heures au
commissariat de Tourcoing pour faire
cela alors qu'on pourrait très bien le
faire de façon numérique alors la
disposition dans lequel pour lequel
ceinture de Bresse m'a interrogé c'est
que lui il encadrait la visio qu'au
plainte pour les biens
et nous disons NON discutons de
l'ensemble des plaintes parce que il
appartient sans doute peut-être au
législateur de regarder davantage mais
que les plaintes qui méritent des
examens médicaux des questionnements
plus intimes des accompagnements
psychologiques
mérite évidemment de se faire en
physique d'ailleurs je voudrais dire ici
pas en physique seulement dans le
commissariat nous faisons nous
expérimentons on n'a pas besoin de
mesurer législatives pour ça le allez
vers comme dans la vaccination
aujourd'hui les policiers gendarmes dans
dix départements de France vont chez
l'avocat vont chez la maman vont chez la
cousine vont CCAS vont dans la commune
pour pas recevoir la dame notamment si
c'est une violence intraphaël une
agression sexuelle dans le commissariat
mais dans l'association venir prendre la
plainte grâce aux moyens qu'on les
policiers gendarmes pour faire des
choses désormais à distance mais il y a
un certain nombre de plaintes y compris
qui touche
physiquement les personnes qui peuvent
être totalement déposées effectivement
de manière visio à la condition qu'un
certain nombre d'éléments soient réunis
notamment l'identité numérique pour
qu'on soit certains que cette personne
soit la bonne personne qui dépose
plainte donc on aura l'occasion d'en
parler mais ça me paraîtrait absurde que
seul l'administration de la police
nationale et la gendarmerie ne puisse
pas utiliser le numérique pour
simplifier la vie de nos concitoyens je
dirais que dans l'absurdité parfois
misérateur et le dernier nous avons été
les derniers à pouvoir faire voler des
drones en France tout le monde pouvait
faire voler des drones sauf les
policiers et les gendarmes grâce à la
grâce à la à l'action des rapporteurs ce
rapporteur nous avons pu réussir à faire
voler ces drones quand renseignement
d'ailleurs et pas en judiciaire ce qui
était d'une autre question qui nous a
beaucoup occupé le sénateur Hervé évoqué
RRF je veux dire que d'abord le
gouvernement a essayé de déposer le
moins d'amendement possible et mettez
parlementaire moi-même je reviendrai
sans doute un jour ministre sait très
bien mais mais c'est pas un CDI je
voudrais dire
monsieur le ministre de Bresse monsieur
monsieur le rapporteur Hervé que nous
déposons deux amendements
gouvernementaux
je veux dire que c'est quand même je
crois aussi à signe positif vis-à-vis du
travail parlementaire et notamment l'un
des deux c'est la demande de la
commission du Sénat que le transformer
l'ordonnance en dur bon nous l'avons
fait nous avons vu que c'était pas
facile nous l'avons fait et donc ceci
pour ça que c'est un moment sera certes
long mais respectueux je crois des
droits à parlementaires puisque nous
revoyons pas ça à une ordonnance alors
beaucoup de questions ont été posées
ensuite par les orateurs je vais essayer
de les séries madame la Présidente mais
gageons que ça fasse gagner du temps
dans la discussion d'amendement si les
parlementaires se sentent éclairés
madame Jourda et Monsieur le roi à
l'instant que je remercie de sa
participation bobo la sécurité comme le
sénateur du Rhin évoquait la question
des répartitions police gendarmerie bon
je sais que ça passionne absolument tout
le monde et notamment les sénateurs
particulièrement encore plus quand les
sénateurs sont parfois en campagne
électorale ça peut arriver mon
département est renouvelable je voudrais
constaté d'ailleurs qu'il y a quatre
députés 4 sénateurs du Nord entre madame
la Présidente le rapporteur et ce qui
interviennent qui ont évoqué les sujets
ce qui montre à quel point le Nord est
en force voilà je ne suis pas candidat
au sénatorial je voudrais ici rassurer
mais mais mes amis mes amis collectivent
je dis non mais tout député rêve d'être
sénateur un jour mais je je en tout cas
ça ne vaut pas pour ce renouvellement si
madame la Présidente
mais comme je suis grand électeur vous
remarquerez dans mon département que
tous les les que tous les bon
anniversaire ce qui montre qu'ils
tiennent bien leurs fichier de grosses
détecteurs mais je la remercie parce que
je sais que je sais mais la présidente
que ça vient du cœur voilà non je veux
dire blague à part que cette zone de
police gendarmerie bien sûr je dis au
sénateur Leroy je dis à la rapporteur
Jodha se pose
alors elle n'est pas à mon avis
si difficile à faire a priori parce que
en fait peu de texte législatif viennent
convoquer la répartition entre la police
et la gendarmerie si c'était un article
un article du code général des
collectivités territoriales qui prévoit
que au dessus d'un certain nombre
d'habitants 20 000 me semble-t-il de
mémoire en dessous c'est une zone
gendarmerie au sud police et désormais
il y a quelques exceptions qui ne
confirment pas la règle puisque par
exemple si je prends le cas de Libourne
est en zone gendarmerie alors que
l'augmentation de la population a été
beaucoup plus forte
je réponds deux fois à votre
argumentation et c'est pas les lobbies
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
sénateur pardon qui m'ont poussé à ne
pas proposer cette nouvelle répartition
et donc je n'ai pas repris cette
proposition pas tellement du Beauvau si
vous remettez mais plutôt du Livre blanc
de la sécurité d'abord si je rentre
aujourd'hui dans une répartition police
gendarmerie je fais naître à mon
administration une discussion sociale
extrêmement forte puisque c'est pas si
simple que ça les gendarmes dorment dans
leur caserne avec leurs familles les
policiers ne vivent pas dans leur
commissariat donc c'est plus compliqué
qu'il n'y paraît et donc il faut des
projets immobiliers il faut un
accompagnement social et nous allons
passer des mois et des mois et c'est
bien normal à l'accompagner et
deuxièmement nous aurons donc une
discussion avec les collectivités
locales sur cette question un peu longue
et c'est bien logique je pense qu'au
moment où la délinquance est forte où
nous devons organiser face aux crises
que j'ai évoqué le ministère d'intérieur
qui a pris beaucoup de retard sur le
cyber la lutte contre le terrorisme et
organiser les Jeux Olympiques
je ne suis pas certain que l'énergie du
miso intérieur et de tous ses services
doit être aujourd'hui se concentrer sur
la répartition police gendarmerie au
niveau de territorial je ne dis pas que
ici ou là à saint-andré-de-chausses ne
le mérite pas notamment l'outre-mer mais
pas que je dis que à choisir ses combats
et je crois qu'ils sont nombreux dans ce
que j'essaie de mener dans la priorité
ce n'est pas la priorité première que
j'ai souhaité mettre en place ici la
priorité première c'est la lutte contre
la délinquance les premiers chiffres
dévoiler ce matin montrent que la
stratégie on y reviendra de présence de
voie publique apporte un certain nombre
de solutions 23% de baisse de violence
aux personnes en moins par rapport à
l'année dernière c'est la première fois
en 4 ans qui vient sans personne baisse
bon donc je pense que l'énergie doit se
concentrer là-dessus et dans la réussite
de la Coupe du monde de rugby et des JO
donc plusieurs d'entre vous ont évoqué
et pas sur ce sujet qui est certes
importants mais qui n'est pas le plus
important deuxième sujet je me pose la
question de ce sénateur madame la
sénatrice de savoir si cette répartition
territoriale posait la question n'est
pas y répondre je me pose la question en
toute sincérité n'est pas un peu daté
est-ce que la délinquance d'aujourd'hui
fonctionne seulement par territoire tel
que nous l'avons connu comme une par
commune est-ce qu'on ne se dit pas que
le territoire numérique qui fait naître
une délinquance territoriale les points
de Deal sont numériques le Dark web fait
naître une monnaie numérique des
échanges d'armes se font sur un
territoire numérique est-ce que ça ne
vient pas un peu casser les réflexions
il y a encore 20 ou 30 ans de la
répartition police gendarmerie les lieux
de transport aujourd'hui les zones de
transport si je prends l'agglomération
toulousaine qui prend 15000 habitants
par an fait que les lieux de transport
c'est à côté police côté zone police un
côté gendarmerie côté gendarmerie est-ce
qu'on doit pas imaginer que la police
aujourd'hui doit être compétente selon
non pas des territoires de délinquance
mais des thématiques de délinquance tu
as tout à fait imaginé que la
gendarmerie ou la police soit
spécialiste de l'intégralité des
transports parce que on s'arrête pas une
station de métro ou une station de bus
parce que c'est quand même de la
gendarmerie qui vont prendre la suite je
connais des requêtes d'autoroute qui
sont en de police avec les CRS et des
autoroutes cet homme regarde qui sont
gendarmerie zone gendarmes mobiles
est-ce qu'on se dit pas que c'est un peu
absurde d'ailleurs on nous parlons
d'imaginer en territoire poser la
question n'est pas y répondre
définitivement mais je crois que cette
réflexion n'était pas tout à faite et
renforcée par une première argument que
ce départ la priorité du moment et ça
laissera du travail pour les autres
mises à l'intérieur parce qu'après tout
on peut pas tout faire en une seule fois
et donc j'en suis j'en suis très heureux
n'y voyez aucun conservatisme monsieur
le sénateur voyait-y à la fois une
hiérarchie des priorités et une
réflexion sur ce qu'est la délinquance
je voudrais évoquer la question de la
méthode sur les brigades de gendarmerie
qui intéresse évidemment tout le monde
je suis surpris monsieur sénateur Bourgy
mais c'était une invitation au voyage
finalement vous disiez que les élus
étaient inquiets qu'on leur proposait
des brigades en plus ah j'avoue que je
n'ai pas encore vu de pétition des
locaux pour me dire moins de brigades de
gendarmerie mais dès qu'il y en a je je
m'engagerai à ne pas mettre de brigades
dans ce département si tout le monde le
demande sans aucun sans aucun problème
nous allons recréer 200 brigades de
gendarmerie et je veux ici souligner que
nous c'est pas des promesses du lapin
comme on dit dans le Nord puisque nous
avons la création de 52% d'effectifs
dans la police et 48% dans la
gendarmerie c'est la première fois qu'a
mise à l'intérieur propose un quasi
parité le nombre de policiers nombre de
gendarmes et c'est notamment fait parce
que nous recréons ces deux sans brigades
à peu près 10 militaires par brigade
évidemment c'est une moyenne un peu
technocratique ou ça ne veut rien dire
ça ne fait quand même 2000 gendarmes
prévues dans la loi de programmation
dont une très grande partie des budgets
2023 donc dès l'été prochain je suis
capable de réouvrir des brigades de
gendarmerie dans vos départements et
donc c'est vraiment extrêmement concret
comment nous allons faire j'ai commencé
dans le Cher mais je crois que des
représentants évidemment de la haute
assemblée était présente nous réunirons
tous les maires tous les parlementaires
avec le commandant de groupement de la
Gendarmerie avec le préfet et quand il
le pourra avec le ministre et nous
dirons voilà la délinquance dans la zone
gendarmerie de votre département les
forces et les faiblesses les difficultés
les brigades qui ont été supprimées les
augmentations de population les
augmentations de délinquance
les nouveaux les nouveaux projets voilà
où nous pensons qu'il serait bon dans
une zone définie où on peut mettre des
brigades en plus entre 2 et 4 par
département si dans un département il
faut en mettre 5 on en mettra ça et dans
les départements très urbains voilà dans
les Hauts-de-Seine sachant que c'est pas
département de gendarmes vous comprenez
que il y a pas de brigade de gendarmerie
donc évidemment c'est à la louche mais
c'est entre deux quatre ou cinq brigades
par département et nous leur disons une
chose suivante aux élus voici ce que
nous pensons nous comme expert de la
sécurité vous avez trois ou quatre mois
pour réfléchir entre vous comme vous le
souhaitez notamment nous appuyons sur
l'association des mers ruraux et sur
l'association des maires de France
départementale pour dire là c'est bien
mais là c'est pas très bien parce que on
a des projets pavillonnaires on a un
projet économique qui arrive il faut
réfléchir pour les 20 ans qui viennent
et pas seulement à des vacances
d'aujourd'hui et tout le monde sera
consulté a commencé évidemment par les
parlementaires et sur la double
proposition des élus locaux et du
commandant de groupement nos fonds
s'attendent d'arbitrage évidemment mais
je le dis pour les données publics plus
on aura des Locaux Disponibles c'est pas
du tout un chantage c'est une évocation
plus on aura des Locaux Disponibles plus
on pourra vite implanter ces brigades de
gendarmerie mais ça commence par l'État
a des boulots vides dans vos
départements qui n'utilisent pas ou qui
n'a pas rénové c'est le cas de caserne
de militaires c'est le cas d'anciens
endroits du ministère de l'intérieur
mais c'est le cas aussi peut-être d'un
certain nombre de bâtiments publics où
la malheureusement concentration de
l'État a fait qu'on a perdu des
implantations et nous on est prêt
évidemment à payer les rénovations et
les aménagements mais je vais pas non
plus bouder mon plaisir si une
agglomération a des appartements nous
dit on a décidé d'aider une commune à
avoir une brigade de gendarmerie
flambourneuf voilà donc on en reparlera
parce que il y a des amendements
effectivement moi tout à fait prêt à
aller discuter je suis évidemment pas
d'accord sur le montant mais je l'ai
aussi pris comme un comme un appel à la
discussion en tout cas je veux dire que
c'est en parfaite discussion collective
que nous ferons c'est 200 brigades qui
seront toutes
annoncé au mois de mars prochain et dès
l'été prochain pour ceux qui seront
prêts ne pourront créer ces brigades de
gendarmerie puisque nous avons les
effectifs pour Madame assassy
bon je madame j'ai pris votre
intervention d'abord par avec de vraies
questions sur la formation je partage
votre opinion mais c'est un texte
formation je crois qu'il y a pas eu il y
aura pas plus motivation pour former les
policiers gendarmes d'abord nous sommes
le gouvernement qui avait augmenté de 4
mois et c'est le cas aujourd'hui dans
les écoles de police et les écoles
gendarmerie la formation initiale des
gardiens de la paix et des gendarmes
avant il faisait 8 mois maintenant ils
font 12 mois c'est pas mal c'est une
amélioration substantielle et sur la
formation continue madame il n'y a nous
avons deux problèmes un manque de
formateur deux un manque de temps pour
les forces manque de formateurs dans la
programmation que je propose c'est 250
formateurs recrutés en formation
continue ma formation initiale pour la
gendarmerie et 500 pour la police
nationale nous recrutons dans ce texte
750 formateurs encore faut-il former les
formateurs et plus le nous l'avons nous
avons déjà commencé à le faire partant
du principe on aura quand même majorité
pour ce texte il n'y a jamais eu autant
de progrès pour avoir autant de lieux de
formation et de formateurs dans la
police et gendarmerie parce que je suis
bien conscient de ce que vous dites et
vous avez parfaitement raison la
formation permet d'aider les policiers
gendarmes à être respectueux des lois de
la République et aussi protéger leur
propre action juridique ou humaine ça
c'était un des cas du bobo de la
sécurité je pense que les deux sénateurs
qui ont participé ont pu traduire cette
demande forte des forces et puisque nous
ont dit aussi les forces c'est que il y
a des moments où ils ont des formations
il y a des moments où ils peuvent le
faire seulement ils peuvent pas le faire
parce qu'ils sont rappelés par leur
service au moment où je vous parle je
dois 5 semaines de congés payés aux
gendarmes mobiles et au CRS là
maintenant parce que nous les utilisons
tout le temps quand c'est pas des matchs
de football c'est de la police aux
frontières quand c'est pas possible
c'est manifestations du samedi quand
c'est pas les manifestations du samedi
c'est une bassine qui attaquée par je ne
sais quelle
ultra gauche nous utilisons toujours
on peut pas dire le contraire on utilise
on utilise on est hyper personne ici se
relève de l'ultra gauche j'imagine donc
c'est vraiment pas une attaque à domine
nous utilisons beaucoup les CRS et
gendarmes mobiles et donc pourquoi ils
ne sont pas assez formés c'est pas par
manque de formateur c'est par manque
d'effectif et chacun sait qu'on rogne
sur leur congés et sur leur formation
pour qu'ils aillent préparer au plus
pressés c'est-à-dire l'ordre public qui
font du coup un peu moins bien parce
qu'ils sont fatigués parce qu'ils sont
pas assez formés le chat se mord la
queue donc la récréation des 11 unités
de force mobile après la suppression des
15 unités de force mobile c'est aussi
non pas mettre forcément plus de
policiers de gendarme sur le terrain
mais permettent les trois tiers un tiers
de repos un tiers de formation un tiers
d'action et donc là je crois vraiment
madame peut-être que c'était un manque
d'explication de la part mais je pense
vous avoir convaincu je m'impose sur la
victime à distance parce que je pense
que je l'ai évoqué à votre à votre
collègue rapporteur et vous-même vous
savez sans doute qu'il y a du bon sens à
avoir sans doute dans l'utilisation de
l'outil numérique pour le ministère
d'intérieur vous m'a évoqué les pts mais
c'est un très bon exemple la police
scientifique la police technique et
scientifique aujourd'hui n'est pas une
véritable police au sens légal du terme
elle est obligée de demander de faire
des Reiki d'avoir déjà sur l'acquisition
et faire des protocoles pour intervenir
on perd un temps absolument fou il faut
faire confiance aux agents techniques
administratifs et scientifiques du
ministère de l'Intérieur les services de
police ne peuvent pas être seuls de tous
les services à faire des protocoles
entre eux avant d'intervenir voilà une
Gabi administrative et il s'agit pas de
laisser la police technique et
scientifiques sont sans contrôle bien
évidemment et quelle politique pour la
jeunesse vous m'avez dit même à triste
mais la la jeunesse elle est dans les
forces de l'ordre enfin les gardiens de
la paix les les gendarmes dans une école
ils vont ils ont 19 20 21 22 ans c'est
les enfants du peuple c'est pas les
enfants du CAC 40 en général qui font
gardien de la paix on peut le regretter
peut-être mais enfin c'est une vérité et
moi je ne veux pas opposer les forces de
l'ordre à la jeunesse puisque ce sont
des jeunes qui rentrent dans la police
nationale et dans le gendarmerie son
débat soit société on aura évidemment
d'autres moments pour le faire j'imagine
je voudrais évoquer monsieur Durin le
remercier de ces encouragements c'est de
dire comprendre évidemment ces
interrogations j'ai vu qu'il avait
déposé d'un moment je regarderai bien
volontiers dire que par nature je l'ai
dû rapporter je suis très favorable à un
moment qui est déposé avec l'autre
rapporteur de votre mission
d'information sur la préjudiciaire je
viendrai sur la filière judiciaire je
n'ai évidemment aucun sujet avec ça lui
juste le corriger s'il ne le permet
l'immigration n'a jamais été dans la
première version de l'opening voilà donc
ça n'a jamais été le cas d'ailleurs ça
m'est parfois reproché mais la lotmi
était sans l'immigration il y aura un
texte immigration et donc même dans la
version initiale
j'imagine je ne sais pas quelle version
vous avez eu en tout cas pas celle qui a
été rédigée par le ministère de
l'Intérieur donc c'est une c'est une
bonne chose aussi madame Verrien
j'espère que je prononce bien à vous
évoquer les 400 000 affaires de
violences intra familiales vous avez
bien raison je sais pas où est Madame
sénatrice pardon excusez-moi vous avez
parfaitement raison nous doublons
effectivement les enquêteurs spécialisés
tout ce qu'on fait sur la vestigation
c'est en très grande partie pour eux
nous améliorons un certain nombre de
choses et notamment des assistantes
assistant ou assistantes sociales ou
psychologiques je voulais seulement vous
faire remarquer deux choses d'abord oui
monsieur Bourgy je crois et vous-même je
suis personnellement favorable à la
juridiction spécialisée pour les
violences intrafamidales comme le font
les Espagnols donc vous y voyez un
soutien très fort du ministère de
l'Intérieur même si cela relève du
ministre de la Justice j'ai constaté
qu'on a la première ministre avait
évoqué ce sujet et personnellement je
m'en félicite et j'en suis je crois très
heureux parce que ça aidera également
les policiers et les gendarmes à agir
avec des gens devant un contentieux
spécialisé bon même s'ils ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts il faut continuer à
faire ces efforts de formation et de
continuité donc j'y suis favorable
deuxième question je voudrais remarquer
avec vous que 30%
seulement c'est évidemment beaucoup 30%
de trop et qu'on se met prennent pas sur
mes propos des femmes ou des hommes mais
majoritairement des femmes qui sont
tombées sous le coup de leur conjoint
avaient déposé une plainte ou avait fait
un signalement au service de police ou
de justice ça veut donc dire quand même
bien sûr qu'on a très large encore
amélioration à faire dans les services
pour mieux accueillir la parole mais que
ce n'est pas simplement mieux formant
les policiers des gendarmes que vous
arriverez à résoudre le problème vous le
savez bien des violences intrafamiliales
et surtout des féminicides comme nous
disons aujourd'hui il y a donc dans
d'autres pans de la société je pense
personnellement au monde
associatif au monde médical également
des
devoirs d'alerte
qui ne sont pas forcément au rendez-vous
voilà donc faudrait qu'on en parle si
vous le souhaitez dans le cadre de votre
rapport mais ne n'ayons pas aussi comme
l'une de penser que seuls les policiers
légendes pourraient résoudre par une
meilleure formation 100% des féministes
bien sûr ils pourront
réduire au maximum le risque et je pense
qu'on peut toujours faire mieux vous le
savez j'ai pris moi-même des
dispositions extrêmement fortes pour
qu'il y ait meilleur même pas de doute
sur les policiers les gendarmes qui
prennent les plaintes mais ce n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga bien évidemment de la
lutte contre les violences à un train
familial même si c'est une très
importante bien sûr il n'y a pas de
disposition sur l'ordre public comme
vous avez évoqué mais je crois que nous
aurons une loi Jo très bientôt on aura
l'occasion sans doute d'en reparler
monsieur ravier je sais pas s'il est
encore là
mais de là où il est doit nous entendre
en tout cas je l'espère alors Monsieur
ravier bon c'est Monsieur
ravier monsieur ravier alors on était un
peu étonné je crois que c'est rapporteur
sans parler à votre place il évoquait
qu'il y ait pas de disposition pour la
police municipales il a loupé le tome 1
de nos discussions ce qu'on avait mis
dans la sécurité globale et que le
Conseil constitutionnel nous a dit une
chose très simple si vous avez plus loin
dans les pouvoirs donnés aux polices
municipales il faut mettre les polices
municipales sous l'autorité du procureur
de la République bon je connais pas
beaucoup de maires qui souhaitent le
faire s'il y en a qui soit qui soit
volontaire qui n'hésitent pas ou alors
faut changer la constitution ce qui
n'est pas l'objet de notre loi ordinaire
aujourd'hui ce qui est intermédiaire à
Monsieur ravier qu'il est légèrement
antinomique puisque il voudrait donner
plus de pouvoir judiciaire puisque la
préjudiciaire serait forme ce qui est à
mon avis un paradoxe intellectuel
complexe et sur l'immigration monsieur
ravier mais d'une autre manière que de
Monsieur durable dire que il y aura un
autre discussion un autre moment
j'espère qu'on pourra en discuter avec
avec Monsieur ravier monsieur caoutchi a
parlé comme d'autres de la réforme de la
police nationale et je veux donc lui
répondre comme aux autres intervenants
d'abord je veux dire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que j'ai
évidemment
conscience des difficultés des
interrogations qui se posent
comme toute réforme importante et c'est
une réforme très importante c'est une
réforme tellement importante qu'elle a
été pour la première fois demandé par
mon prédécesseur monsieur Jox
alors ça ne réjouira personne mais
Monsieur Jacques s'était mis à
l'intérieur en tout cas maman il a fait
sa réforme au lendemain ne sera deuxième
passage à Beauvau c'est à dire au
lendemain de 1988 et le premier qui
évoquait le fait quelqu'un ici a cité le
grand minisateur qu'il était je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec le sénateur
Leroy en disant que la police nationale
travaillant en silo alors mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs il y a des
moments où vous me dites vous n'écoutez
pas assez le Sénat alors une fois qu'on
écoute Sénat vous dites vous allez trop
vite pourquoi vous faites cette réforme
monsieur le ministre carochi a eu 7
rapports depuis 25 ans fait par des
majorités sénatoriales différentes et
selon le consensus du Sénat avec un
président un rapporteur de couleur
politique différentes qui préconisaient
les sept rapports les 7 dernières
rapports de la police la réforme de la
police nationale que nous mettons en
place
le dernier alors je vais peut-être tous
ces cités mais le dernier en place c'est
Monsieur bouton je crois qu'il était
sénateur du groupe socialiste et
Monsieur Grosdidier il faisait partie de
votre famille politique et que dit le
rapport bouton quotidien page 63 la
police nationale deux points c'est le
titre une institution fortement divisée
tandis que la gendarmerie nationale je
ne dis pas autre chose bénéficie d'une
structure unifiée de commandement et
d'un esprit de corps affirmé la police
nationale souffre de sa forte
segmentation et d'un manque pas tant de
cohésion qui pèse au quotidien sur les
agents comme sur l'efficacité des
services une organisation peut
centraliser et que tu as entre plusieurs
centres de commandement au niveau
national comme au niveau territorial
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est ce que nous faisons
que fait la gendarmerie nationale si
c'est d'avoir un commandement et oui
bien sûr une filière spécialisée qu'on
appelle les sections les
sections de recherche pardon je suis un
peu fatigué c'est pas encore la fête de
mon anniversaire
alors bien sûr il y a des interrogations
on peut toujours en discuter mais moi
j'ai tendance à écouter les sept
rapports sénatoriaux alors Monsieur le
Ministre kaoutchi quand on dit que les
rapports sont faits et que jamais le
gouvernement les applique une fois
qu'ils les applique on dit parce qu'il y
a des gens et c'est normal qui posent
des interrogations auxquelles il faut
répondre ils sont pas forcément tous
contents je vous réponds travaillons-y
ensemble si vous me le permettez alors
pour répondre aux ministres Richard le
calendrier éclair il y a des élections
professionnelles début décembre moi je
vais pas discuter de réforme en
attendant que les syndicats sont en
campagne donc j'attends et c'est normal
donc j'attends que les policiers élisent
leur représentant syndicaux le 15
décembre quelque part les
expérimentations puisque ça a déjà c'est
déjà passé en outre-mer je regarde le
sénateur de Mayotte il pourrait
peut-être témoigner du fait que la dtpn
malgré les difficultés de Mayotte qui
sont grandes et plus efficaces en Guyane
même le procureur général en convient en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe c'est pareil
je reviens de la Savoie
un syndicat de police a fait son son
congrès dans ce département tout le
monde considère que se passe bien dans
ce département il y a d'autres
difficultés dans d'autres départements
j'en conviens bien volontiers je dis
qu'on a attendre ces expérimentations
j'ai même recommandé un rapport de
l'igéa de l'IGPN et j'ai demandé que
l'inspection de la justice il soit il y
a deux rapports sénatoriaux un rapport
sénatorial un rapport de l'Assemblée
nationale le 15 décembre j'aurais ce
rapport je demanderai au syndicat de
venir me voir nous discuterons la
réforme à ce moment-là on amendra ce qui
doit être amendé mais ici je veux vous
dire qu'on ne peut pas rester dans un
monde où on se réfère qu'à Clémenceau
qui était un grand personnage dont bien
sûr je ne serai pas à la hauteur du
petit doigt de l'orteil je veux bien le
dire bien volontiers mais même la
moustache devait pas la hauteur monsieur
le monsieur le sénateur carochi mais
depuis que les morceaux depuis
Clémenceau on a inventé internet on a
inventé la mondialisation aujourd'hui
celui qui est à Dubaï commande la drogue
qui arrive dans le port du Havre de
Marseille et qui descend dans les points
de l'île près de chez vous on a baissé
malheureusement les taux d'élucination
et on ne peut pas se satisfaire de ce
constat que tout le monde fait la Cour
des comptes les deux chambres
parlementaires les anciens directeurs
généraux de la police nationale et se
dire bon bah c'est comme ça puis c'est
tout ne changeons pas les organisations
parce que Clémenceau l'a inventé mais
Clémenceau quand il a créé la police
judiciaire qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il a
constaté qu'il y a un truc qui
fonctionnait pas puisque la criminalité
était organisée il a retiré la police au
pouvoir municipaux mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs voilà ce qu'a fait les
morceaux les villes les communes les
mers et les polices municipales ont
alors fait beaucoup de manifestations il
a forcé c'était le mois démocratique
sans doute à l'époque il a forcé à
s'organiser de la criminel et il a dit
devant une criminalité organisée je fais
une police organisée et ben devant une
criminalité numérique
internationale multiformes qui demandent
désormais à ce que la police des
étrangers sont en lien avec la police
judiciaire qui sont en lien avec la
police de sécurité publique qui sont en
lien avec les renseignements pour
pouvoir lutter contre les délinquants
très fortes que nous connaissons et que
vous dénoncez à juste raison il faut
réformer la police nationale pas contre
tout le monde pas de manière autoritaire
ça fait 30 ans qu'on parle de cette on
en a parlé depuis jobs on en a parlé
dans le Livre blanc de la sécurité je
vais d'ailleurs dire que ceux qui siégé
à l'époque recommandé de faire cette
réforme on en a parlé au bobo de la
sécurité et oui au bout de 30 ans on
s'est dit ce serait peut-être bien de la
faire alors je veux rassurer ici les
magistrats ils auront évidemment
toujours l'immense et entière
responsabilité des enquêtes
seuls eux peuvent donner des des ordres
aux policiers aux gendarmes dans le
cadre de leurs enquêtes personne d'autre
pas le préfet pas de directeur
départemental de la police nationale pas
le directeur général de la police
nationale ils auront le libre choix du
service selon l'article 12 du code de
procédure pénale et évidemment le
question qui sont posées notamment de
probité on fera monter les affaires d'un
niveau local à niveau national puisqu'il
paraît que les préfets les élus parlent
souvent de questions de cet ordre je ne
le crois pas mais je veux bien prendre
l'amendement et donc toutes les affaires
de probité de délinquance financière
seront montés à un niveau qui n'est pas
départemental alors nous allons
continuer à discuter mais évidemment
mais je veux vous dire que ce que nous
faisons là n'est pas sorti des idées
simples du ministre de l'intérieur mais
de 30 ans de réflexion sur pourquoi la
police nationale doit se réformer je le
ferai évidemment concertation mais je
veux dire aussi au parlementaire sans
renier le débat que nous pourrons avoir
que ce ne sont pas des dispositions
législatives et que nous changeons 166
textes réglementaires que nous l'avons
mis par honnêteté dans le rapport annexé
nous discuterons évidemment des
amendements d'ailleurs en acceptant je
crois la quasi intégralité d'entre eux
mais il faut aussi savoir réformer
lorsque c'est réformé je pense que c'est
un ministre de l'Intérieur et merci
d'avoir souligné qui a jamais trouvé
autant de moyens et qui défend je crois
orbi et Orbit les forces de l'ordre qui
peut permettre de leur dire parfois
qu'il faut aussi se réformer en
respectant profondément leur métier leur
filière et leur action parce que la
police a été créée pour les gens et pas
pour nous-mêmes
deuxième
intervention sans doute
plus
critique celle de Monsieur alors
benaroche c'est bien ça voilà
vous me dites monsieur le sénateur de ne
pas faire de la gamme politique facile
en quelque part en mettant le vaccin aux
antidote à ce que je pourrais vous
répondre effectivement pour améliorer je
suis bien noté la souffrance au travail
le sens du métier de la police vaut
mieux pas trop les insulter pas trop
dire que la police tue ça aide aux
policiers à aller mieux je pense dans
leur action mais vous m'avez dites ne
faites pas de politique d'amalgame
à la tribune de l'Assemblée c'est
légèrement excessif bon d'abord parce
que j'ai pas son talent littéraire et
ensuite parce que je suis né en 82 et
pas en 84 mais
oui merci Monsieur d'avoir rapporteur
mais je veux essayer de répondre à votre
à vos critiques plus sur le fond d'abord
vous me dites il faut créer une police
environnementale mais vous allez voter
le texte monsieur le sénateur nous
créons la première gendarmerie verte
puisque la police environnementale est
sans doute une police de l'environnement
aux autres gendarmerie la police de la
gendarmerie verte première fois qu'on le
crée et nous allons renforcer de manière
très importante le Claes l'Office
concerné donc
félicitons-nous de cette avancée très
importante vous nous dites il faut
dénoncer le côté disparate des AFD alors
ça c'est un point très important parce
que dans votre intervention vous avez
dit vous mettez en cause finalement
voici un peu la réforme de la police
nationale vous nous dites vous êtes très
attentif à l'autoritarisme ou un certain
port de sanction et vous regrettez
[Musique]
parce que les magistrats vous semblaient
penser qu'on aura une leur pouvoir la
disparition le fait que soit disparate
entre départements les AFD que l'on met
c'est vrai que les endroits dans Val
d'Oise monsieur ministre Richard le
nombre de grammes de cannabis qui fait
naître la FD n'est pas le même quand sa
voix parce que vous savez quoi il y a un
procureur qui le définit et c'est bien
non pas le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
définit un petit pénal mais les
procurants de la République et c'est
pour ça l'AFD le respecte profondément
l'indépendance des magistrats une fois
que vous aurez voté tel législation
imaginons l'amande forfaitaire des
cuelle pour la consommation de cannabis
une fois que nous l'avons voté c'est les
procureurs de la République qui prennent
une circulaire dans leur ressort et qui
dit au service de police la loi a dit ça
mais moi je dis que 15 g de cannabis
c'est très grave et donc je déferrai et
je demande qu'on interpelle je demande
la garde à vue je demande la procédure
et puis il y a des départements comme
dans Val d'Oise on pense que 15 g de
cannabis bon on en voit beaucoup donc on
préfère se concentrer à faire le 30 g en
dessous de 30 g bah on fait la FD au
dessus de 30 g on défaire mais c'est
procureur qui décide c'est pas le
commissaire de police s'est mise à
l'intérieur ou le gardien de la paix
alors parfois ça peut apparaître
disparaître des fois accepter que les
procureurs ne répondent effectivement
pas tous aux mises à justice au
ministère de l'Intérieur d'ailleurs il
ne recommande pas évidemment les ordres
de la place bobo donc vous arrivez à
défendre dans votre démonstration
monsieur le sénateur à la fois qu'on
doit laisser tout liberté au magistrat
et quand c'est disparate selon les
ressorts vous dites il y a trop
disparaît de trop de différence entre
les ressorts la petite pénale monsieur
le Center n'est pas définie par le
ministre de l'intérieur elle est définie
par le garde des sceaux mais surtout par
les circulaires pénales est-ce que nous
vous demandons c'est rien d'autre que de
permettre à la sanction que de
s'appliquer puisque les listes de dédits
que nous allons évoquer ne connaissent
pas de sanctions sauf le rappel à la loi
qui n'est pas une sanction au sens de
nos concitoyens et quand quelqu'un fait
un tag personne ne peut accepter bien
sûr qu'il aille en prison ce serait
absurde et même le code pénal prévoit
malheureusement qu'il aille en prison
c'est juste dire mais il faut qu'il y a
une sanction parce que s'il y a pas de
sanction quand on commet un tag on
appelle à le recommencer donc le débat
que nous aurons monsieur le sénateur
c'est pas est-ce qu'on se substitue ou
pas au juge franchement je pense que
c'est pas le sujet le débat que nous
aurons c'est est-ce que nous considérons
que les délits que nous évoquons
méritent la contravention avec
inscription casier judiciaire sous
l'autorité des procureur ou mérite une
procédure pénale c'est d'autant plus
vrai que celui qui a créé les AFD pour
sécurité routière ce sont des
gouvernements de gauche
si si on voulait se parce que les AVD
avant d'être créés sur le délit pénal
tout court érotique créé sur les délits
qui étaient auparavant du Delhi pénale
soit sécurité routière si vous n'aviez
pas de permis de conduire par exemple
vous pouvez vous prendre une fdfd
sécurité routière donc c'est pas un
débat d'atteinte à la justice de notre
pays c'est un débat d'efficacité de
simplicité je pense qu'il faut pas
mettre des mauvais débats si vous
permettez ce point de vue là où ils ne
sont pas
monsieur Bourgis a évoqué les défis PDR
j'étais très étonné de votre
intervention je sais pas ce qui se passe
dans les roues je vais demander au
préfet Mutu rapidement ce qui fait de
son argent parce que en 2022 il y avait
5 millions de plus en 2021 sur la FIPD
pour les caméras vidéoprotection c'était
déjà 5 millions de plus qu'en 2019 non
mais après c'est reparti par par
département peut-être que Monsieur
Delafosse prend tout l'argent je c'est
possible on va on va en parler avec on
va parler avec Monsieur maire de
Montpellier et dans le budget 2023 c'est
5 millions de plus et sera 5 millions
chaque année de plus donc je vais
regarder ce qui se passe dans l'Hérault
et je je vais donc m'étonner auprès du
préfet Mutu que vous ne soyez qu'on nous
réponde que il y a plus d'argent parce
que malheureusement j'ose dire de ce
point de vue l'argent il y en a et je
demande plutôt aux élus de le dépenser
il y a encore des maires qui pensent que
caméra de vidéoprotection c'est pas bien
il y a même des mères qui m'ont dit il y
a des mères qui m'ont dit que c'était
dangereux monsieur le sénateur du Rhône
dangereux que les policiers surveillent
les caméras bon voilà je crois que vous
les connaissez très bien vous quêtes du
département du Rhône donc je suis très
heureux que dans le groupe socialiste
des gens me demandent des caméras de
vidéoprotection donc ce que je
trouverais de l'argent évidemment pour
tous ordinateur socialistes qui
demandent des caméras de vidéos
protection
c'est normal
sur les lapis sur les lapis vous avez
parfaitement raison alors c'est tout à
fait réglementaire moi je m'engage à ce
que les maires puissent obtenir la
compétence sur les Happy c'est un tout
petit peu plus complexe regarde Monsieur
Votre présentant la CNIL Monsieur Hervé
ce que je pense que c'est plutôt s'il me
permet lui qu'il faut comprendre que moi
mais évidemment c'est réglementaire je
vais essayer je vais essayer c'était une
interpellation sympathique monsieur le
répondeur je vais essayer de vous
répondre ici la deuxième le deuxième le
deuxième retour vous m'avez évoqué les
brigades de gendarmerie mais je pense
que je vous ai répondu également vous
avez parlé des effectifs je crois que à
Montpellier peuvent pas se plaindre des
effectifs que le ministre de l'Intérieur
accorde me semble-t-il parce que
effectivement il faut travailler pour
lutter contre contre la délinquance je
terminerai madame la Présidente puisque
je vous imagine un patiente
c'est sur les propositions en tout cas
les interventions de Monsieur Wade et de
Monsieur Dominati
il a dit quelque chose de très juste
parmi toutes les choses qu'il a dit et
je reviens pas sur la PJ puisque j'en ai
parlé il dit voilà
les conditions matérielles c'est très
important et jusqu'à présent c'était pas
super vous avez parfaitement mieux dit
mais je ne suis pas votre place monsieur
vous avez parfaitement raison quand
j'étais ministre des comptes publics
j'étais toujours étonné de voir que
Mister à l'intérieur était un des seuls
ministères où le T2 le personnel les
dépenses de personnel étaient
grandissant et le heur T2 les dépenses
matériels étaient en proportion
rapetissant et je me doutais que ça
pouvait pas bien marcher parce que si
vous augmentez sans cesse les effectifs
et les moyens humains
y compris d'ailleurs en rémunération
mais que vous n'accompagnez pas ça de
moyens technologiques matériels de
commissariat de brigade de gendarmerie
de véhicules
évidemment qui a une distorsion et on a
tous fait des tours avec les policiers
et gendarmes avec la voiture qui avait
quasiment le fil de fer qui sortait
aujourd'hui je ne dis pas que c'est pas
que cette carte partout mais je pense
qu'ils ont vu l'énorme effort que nous
avons tous consenti grâce à vous en
mettant dans le plan de relance la
police gendarmerie ce qui était pas
évident au début et 5008 en sont je
crois la plus belle vitrine mais c'est
pas vrai que pour les 5008 c'est vrai
pour l'ensemble du matériel je peux vous
faire le détail du bilan du quinquennat
précédent mais ce que nous essayons de
faire est la loi que nous présentons à
une stratégie budgétaire c'est qu'il
faut que le T2 augmente autant voire
moins que le heur T2 et je redire ici à
la représentation nationale que c'est le
premier texte qui prévoit plus de crédit
qui n'est pas de personnel et qui est de
matériel et technologies c'est la
première fois que nous nous en dire au
policiers aux gendarmes bien sûr on crée
des bien sûr on peut imaginer un certain
nombre d'augmentations de rémunération
ce que nous faisons mais ce qui est
important pour vous c'est le rattrapage
technologique matériel et les casernes
les brigades les commissariats que nous
devons rénover recréer mutualisés plutôt
que toujours donner un chèque de plus
voilà et ça je pense que c'est très
important parce que c'est la stratégie
budgétaire qui est derrière ces 15
milliards et vous devez les convaincu
monsieur le Center que quand je vous dis
que sur les 15 milliards il y en a 7 à 8
qui sont sur numérique et le cyber ça
paraît pas évident pour nos concitoyens
parce que ce qu'ils veulent c'est ici et
maintenant des policiers et des moyens
matériels les policiers veulent ici et
maintenant des moyens matériels mais
nous nous pensons que pour les aider à
gagner demain la bataille contre les
vacances ce qui évoquait le sénateur
carochi nous devons éviter de prendre un
train de retard comme d'habitude et
rattraperez simplement par le numéraire
ce qu'on n'arrivait pas à leur donner
comme matériel et moi je souhaite que
cette loi marque aussi un changement
dans la politique budgétaire du
ministère de l'Intérieur et qui prévoit
comme dans l'armée que le est aussi
important que les moyens humains c'est
pour ça que nous essayons de faire une
autre programmation enfin monsieur le
sénateur Dominati je terminerai par là
puisque je crois que Monsieur Leroy a eu
sa réponse
d'abord ce sénateur Dominati vous avez
eu la gentillesse de rappeler qu'on
était peu de choses puisque je suis le
7e ministre en 7 ans bon alors quand je
suis arrivé au ministère à l'intérieur
les syndicats police m'ont dit vous
savez les ministres passent ces
syndicalistes restent c'était un mot un
moment très sympathique j'ai déjà vu
quatre départs de responsable syndicaux
depuis que je suis là donc je commence à
faire des congrès syndicaux pour dire
vous savez les syndicalistes passent des
Miss Soares il se trouve que sur 7 ans
je suis quasiment fait deux ans et demi
donc votre formule était belle mais peu
juste dans trois mois et demi il me
semble-t-il j'aurais atteint le niveau
de vie de Monsieur Cazeneuve
si je termine l'année 2023 j'aurai
dépassé celui de Monsieur de faire
et si je vais jusqu'au Jeux Olympiques
j'aurais été au niveau juste en dessous
de Monsieur Marcellin qui a très bien
connu le sénateur de Brest je crois ça
pour vous dire que je suis d'accord avec
vous qu'il faut durer et endurer sans
doute au ministère de l'Intérieur et
durée pour faire des réformes en
profondeur
et moi je suis très heureux que le
Président de la République n'est pas
confirmé ça à l'intérieur pour le
principe d'être ministre mais pour enfin
mettre du temps long au ministère de
l'intérieur parce que la moyenne est
mise intérieure pendant ces 7 dernières
années ça a été moins d'un an vous ne
pouvez pas faire des réformes
structurelles vu l'actualité vu
l'urgence que traite un ministre de
l'Intérieur si vos directeurs votre
personnel Bercy dans son illustration
est persuadé que vous allez passer vite
donc moi je souhaite je ne dépends je ne
sais pas propriétaire de mon poste mais
plus longtemps je resterai plus
longtemps j'essaierai de porter des
réformes qui permettent de voir loin et
de transformer fondamentalement la
police alors je sais que vous évoquez
deux grandes réformes l'une que nous
mettons en Une de notre
programmation et l'autre que nous ne
mettons pas le doublement de la présence
policière et gendarmesse sur le terrain
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs c'est
très important parce que je crois que
c'est le cœur de notre discussion
aujourd'hui si on sort le cyber
ce n'est pas le doublement de la
présence du nombre de policiers au
gendarmes c'est le doublement de la
présence policière
il y a des effectifs en plus on vous en
a demandé 10 000 dans le quinquennat
précédent dont 4000 sont partis au
service de renseignement et donc à peu
près 6000 seulement si j'ose dire dans
les forces de police nous vous en
demandons 8500 pour le quinquennat
suivant il est sûr que plus de policiers
gendarmes fait plus de présence sur la
voie publique mais ce n’est pas
suffisant comment nous allons doubler la
présence de voies publiques d'abord nous
allons faire faire des efforts aux
policiers et gendarmes sur leur taux
horaire
nous avons mis en place le système qui
fait que là où il fallait 1 8 policiers
pour caler un sur la voie publique
maintenant il faut cette policiers pour
caler un sur la voie publique ça vous
paraît peut-être déjà trop peu mais on a
fait un effort dans tous les
commissaires de France désormais nous
sommes passés à ce qu'on appelle le
rythme binaire amélioré par tel ou tel
endroit dans quelques commissariats la
troisième des choses c'est les réserves
ce qui marchait admirablement bien pour
la gendarmerie nationale n'existait pas
pour la police nationale c'est un
excellent sujet police population que
des boulangers des ouvriers des cadres
des petits patrons des grands patrons
des moyens patrons aille passer quelques
jours sous l'uniforme après une
formation pour travailler dans la police
nationale et de temps en temps aussi le
rapporte expérience de la vie
professionnelle de la société civile
c'est la réserve soit la création de la
réserve de la police nationale qui est
une énorme avancée pour la police
nationale soit et ça a été dit tout à
l'heure à la tribune par la commission
de la défense je le dis devant le
rapporteur de la commission de la
défense qui s'est exprimé tout à l'heure
nous allons sanctifier les crédits de
réserve qui par manque de bonne cohésion
budgétaires faisait qu'au mois d'août
septembre vos commandes groupement
n'avaient plus les moyens d'avoir la
réserve puisque c'était des crédits les
plus facilement annulables et c'est ce
qu'on faisait voter dans le pdfr
désormais grâce à la loi que je propose
100% des crédits de réserve seront gelés
au sens où ils ne pourront pas être
justement dégelé et ça contribuera
évidemment à la présence au doublement
de la présence quatrièmement la
simplification de la procédure pénale
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs en deux
ans on a fait une réforme sans doute que
vous ne voyez pas de manière
considérable ne fait pas là une des 20h
mais c'est ce genre de téléphone ceci
est un iPhone j'en suis désolé mais
d'une d'un téléphone Neo con désormais
tous les policiers et tous les gendarmes
sur eux fabriqués d'ailleurs par une
entreprise française une PME
d'Aix-en-Provence que je que je vous
demande de promouvoir
grâce à cet outil ce qui n'était pas le
cas lorsque je suis arrivé au ministère
d'intérieur il ne l'avait pas tous et
pas dans ces conditions les policiers
gendarmes ne retournent pas à la caserne
ne retourne pas au commissariat pour
regarder le fichier pour mettre la
contravention pour pouvoir faire un
certain nombre d'analyse qui leur
passait auparavant qui ont été pardon
beaucoup de temps il fallait appeler le
si il fallait que le cycle réponse qui
arrive au commissariats beaucoup de
temps désormais ils font tout grâce tous
grâce à leur téléphone individualisé et
le réseau radio du futur mesdames
messieurs ce sera la radio sur ce
téléphone là vous voyez les gens qui ont
une Grosse Radio quand ils vous
accompagne lorsqu'ils sont en filature
c'est très pratique d'avoir une Grosse
Radio quand on fait une filature en
civile dans un an c'est fini et tout
sera sur ce téléphone et on y verra des
images de radio en même temps que le son
de radio est l'ensemble de la police et
de gendarmerie et peut-être demain des
pompiers et peut-être demain des douanes
ou l'administration pénitentiaire aura
le même réseau donc en faisant ce genre
de simplification qui ne sont certes pas
la une de tous les journaux nous
permettons plus de présence de voter
pendant qu'ils sont pas au en train de
vérifier les fichiers ils sont sur la
voie publique évidemment la procédure
pénale à son importance et je veux dire
à l'ensemble des sénateurs qui m'ont
interpellé sur la procédure pénale nous
faisons-nous de la petite procédure
pénale simplifiée va venir un moment du
garde des sceaux le président de la
République il l'a dit pendant le cadre
du bobo de la sécurité va demander qu'on
simplifie par exemple l'enquête
préliminaire et l'enquête de flagrance
en une seule en seule cadre d'enquête
c'est un travail de temps gagné
considérable pour les services de police
donc je voudrais vous convaincre
monsieur le sénateur que le doublement
de la présence policière elle est fondée
sur une vraie stratégie budgétaire d'où
la programmation et de transformation du
ministère de l'intérieur alors pourquoi
nous réformons pas la préfecture de
police faut-il réformer la préfecture de
police pour je sais que vous vous dites
oui la préfecture de police vous le
savez madame messieurs les sénateurs
date de son histoire sans faire de
mauvais jeux de mots tautologique
à Paris le maire n'a pas le port de
police car les autres mères faut-il lui
donner une réflexion que le Parlement
doit avoir mais Paris c'est pas
n'importe quelle ville d'abord c'est une
ville où il y a tous les lieux de
pouvoir commencer par vos assembler et
c'est une ville qui connaît rien que les
villes de Paris 23% de la délinquance de
toute la France quand vous tenez la
délinquance à Paris vous tenez une
grande partie de la délinquance faut-il
donc des moyens exceptionnels pour un
endroit exceptionnel j'ai plutôt
tendance à répondre oui
bon deuxième sujet faut-il mais j'ai
répondu à une question d'actualité de
votre à votre demande monsieur le
sénateur faut-il entamer la réforme
difficile de la préfecture de police au
moment où nous devons gagner la victoire
contre la délinquance qui est très forte
à Paris songer que cet été au 14 juillet
il y a eu plus de voitures brûlées à
Paris qu'un ayant Seine-Saint-Denis ce
qui montre aussi un changement me
semble-t-il de l'urbanisme et de la
politique parisienne mais je ne fais que
constater moi qui regarde des choses de
manière non politique au sens électoral
du terme et ça doit poser des questions
à un certain nombre de de d'observateurs
et deuxièmement au moment nous allons
organiser les Jeux Olympiques
je ne suis pas certain qu'il faut
bousculer le fonctionnement certes
original mais quand même performant la
préfecture de police pendant le moment
où nous allons organiser les Jeux
Olympiques 600 000 personnes par la
série une ouverture alors vous me direz
il y a toujours un bon moment pour pas
réformer bon mais moi la commande la
mission que j'ai donnée au préfet de
police de Paris préfet de police je lui
ai donné deux missions je lui dis ah
faire baisser la délinquance de réussir
les JO
si
m'approchant de la longévité de Monsieur
Marcellin
je survis à la Haute Assemblée
au chiffre de la délinquance aux aléas
que le ministre d'intérieur peut
connaître qui tous les jours
s'accumulent sur son bureau
à la dissolution d'assemblée nationale
à la réussite de la Coupe du monde de
rugby et des Jeux Olympiques et quand
septembre 2024 monsieur le sénateur
Dominati vous me dites monsieur le
ministre après la loterie après la
baisse de la délinquance après la
réussite de la Coupe du monde et des JO
quel chantier ouvrez-vous peut-être que
j'aurai une réponse différente
merci monsieur le ministre
je vais suspendre la séance pour
quelques minutes la séance est suspendue
[Musique]